Hello, and welcome to this Free Code Camp
course on algorithmic trading and Python.
My name is Nick McCollum, I'm going to be
your instructor for this course. And in this
course, we're going to focus on building three
large quantitative finance projects. In the
first project, we are going to build an equal
weight version of the popular s&p 500 index
fund. In the second project, we are going
to build a quantitative momentum strategy
that selects the best stocks based on a variety
of momentum, investing metrics. And in the
third project, we're going to build a quantitative
value screener that select stocks that are
attractive based on a number of value metrics.
So that's a quick summary of the three projects
that we are going to build in this course.
Before we move into learning more about the
course and those projects, I have a couple
of housekeeping items that have to go over
first, to start this Free Code Camp course
on algorithmic trading. And Python is made
possible through a grant from IE x cloud.
If you've ever read the book, flash boys by
Michael Lewis, you may have heard of it. In
this course, we're gonna be using some other
tools and API's to populate some of the data
that we will need for these algorithmic trading
strategies. The other quick thing that you're
going to notice starting now is a little message
at the bottom of your screen that's going
to stay there for the rest of the video. And
what that message intends to represent is
that this course is for educational purposes
only, I'm going to be providing some high
level finance concepts, but nothing in this
course or in this video should be construed
as investment advice. So just to reiterate,
this course, is for educational purposes only.
And none of this should be considered investment
advice. So with all of that out of the way,
let's dig into a little bit more about what
this course is going to teach you. So let's
start by just going over a quick course overview.
The first thing that we're going to discuss
is some basics of the field of algorithmic
trading. Then we're going to discuss some
API basics, and kind of just quickly go over
how the course is configured and laid out.
The next thing we're going to discuss is the
first project of this course, which is an
equal way version of the popular s&p 500 index
fund. And then we're going to talk about our
second project, which, as I mentioned earlier,
is a quantitative momentum strategy. And then
we're going to discuss briefly our third project,
which is a quantitative value strategy. So
that's kind of a 30,000 foot view of what
you're going to be learning in this course.
Let's zoom in a little bit and talk about
some algorithmic trading basics. So for anyone
who's completely unfamiliar with algorithmic
trading, it basically means using computers
to make investment decisions. So in the past,
where you may have had a team of financial
analysts or investment researchers to kind
of consider stocks and decide what to buy.
Many of the popular investing strategies that
are implemented today actually use more computers
than they do humans. So algorithmic trading
just means using computers to make investment
decisions. Now, there are many different types
of algorithmic trading, on the one hand, you
have, you know, your super high frequency
trading Big Brain, really, really sophisticated
complex strategies. And then at the other
end of the spectrum, you can kind of basically
map any type of fundamental strategy that
humans have have led in the past, and just
make it a little more efficient by providing
some computer software in there. So as you
know, this slide kind of alludes to the main
difference between the many different types
of algorithmic trading is generally the speed
at which those trades are executed. Now, before
we actually dig into more about the world
of algorithmic trading, it's kind of helpful
to have a high level understanding of who
the main players are in this space. And one
of the reasons I wanted to kind of provide
this information at the start of this course
is so that you can see that the field of algorithmic
trading is very big. And if you do want to
make a career that there are lots of employers
lots of opportunities and lots of jobs in
this space. So right now, I'm just going to
briefly discuss a few of the largest players
in the algorithmic trading landscape. The
first one, which is kind of the 50,000 pound
gorilla in the room is Renaissance technologies.
I believe they're based in Long Island, and
they have $165 billion in assets under management.
Now, Renaissance technologies is mostly famous
for their Medallion Fund, which is only open
to employees at this point, which I think
has returned something insane, like 50%, a
year for 20 years or something like that.
Now, none of us can access that fund because
it's for employees only. But Renaissance technologies
probably has one of the best performing investment
funds in the history of finance, and perhaps
most interestingly, is that Renaissance technologies
was not founded by a finance major or a investment
analyst to start. The person who actually
started Renaissance technologies was a math
PhD from, I believe, a California University.
His name's Jim Simons, and many people would
kind of consider him to be one of the forefathers
of quantitative finance. So that's kind of
the largest player in this space. Another
popular one is AQR Capital Management, which
was founded by Cliff Asness and a few other
managing partners and they have $61 billion
in assets under management. Now, unlike Renaissance
technologies, AQR Capital Management actually
has strategy and you're not gonna invest it
through mutual funds and other types of strategies.
And one last interesting thing about that
firm is that their name is kind of the IBM
of investment firms where IBM is International
Business Machines a very bland name, AQR Capital
Management, the AQR component of that name
actually stands for Applied quantitative research.
So if you've ever curious what that stands
for, That's what it is. The last one is Citadel
securities, which has $32 billion in assets
under management. And they're a much more
high frequency trading firm. And the first
two that I mentioned, kind of famous for their
role in the market making space. So they were
founded by Ken Griffin. And that kind of summarizes
three of the large players, you can tell by
just the assets under management of these
three firms alone, more than 200 billion,
that there are lots of opportunities and jobs.
And this is a very large space. So definitely
something worth learning a bit about. Now,
in this course, as you probably have can tell
by the title, we are going to be using Python
for these algorithmic trading strategies.
Now, before we begin actually how to use Python
and how to write the code for it, there's
a few high level things you should understand.
The first one is that Python is probably the
most popular programming language for algorithmic
trading. And the reason why is just because
it has a lot of libraries. But the downside
to using Python is that it's a fairly slow
programming language. So if you want to execute
high performance code, Python is typically
not your best bet. Now, the solution that
many practitioners have found for this is
that Python is often used as a glue language
to trigger code that actually runs in other
languages. A common example of this is the
NumPy library for Python. And that's actually
a library that we'll be using in this course.
Now, NumPy is the most popular Python library
for performing numerical computing. And it's
perhaps most popular for its data structure
called the NumPy array, which easily allows
you to store and manipulate one or two dimensional
data structures in Python. Now, although NumPy
is actually a Python library, and it is called
and manipulated using the Python programming
language, the core underlying functionality
is written in C, which is a much faster language
and provide lots of performance enhancements
to Python users who use the NumPy library
in their code. So just to quickly summarize,
the main idea of this section is that Python
is the most popular programming language for
quantitative finance. But it's also a slow
language. So a lot of times you will use Python
to trigger functionality that actually runs
in other programming languages that are faster.
So now let's quickly talk about the algorithmic
trading process can kind of be broken down
into the following steps, the first step is
to collect data, the second step is to develop
a hypothesis for a strategy. The third step
step is to back test that strategy. Now, back
testing just means formulating your strategy,
and then seeing how it would have performed
historically over time. And generally, there's
kind of two ways you want to do that you want
to take the strategy back as far back in time
as you can, and across as many markets as
you can. So to provide a quick example, let's
say that you have a hypothesis that the largest
firms outperform, you would probably want
to test that here in the United States, and
go back as far back in time as you can. And
then you would also want to test the performance
of the largest firms in Canada, Europe, Japan,
China, India, all the other international
markets as well. And if that strategy performs
well in all of those markets, then you can
be sure that you're probably on to something.
Now, the fourth strategy would be to implement
that we're sorry, the fourth step rather,
would be to implement that strategy in production.
So you've collected data, you develop a hypothesis,
you've back testing strategy, and now you're
going to start actually trading that strategy
with real money. In real accounts moving forward
and seeing how it does with real money in
the strategy. Now you have a high level understanding
of the algorithmic trading process, there's
a few ways that this course will be different
from a real algorithmic trading strategy.
And I just want to highlight those quickly
right now before we dive into some information
about the three projects we'll be building.
Now, just to quickly summarize the three major
ways that this course will be different. The
first is that we'll be using random data,
the data provider that we're using for this
course, which is is cloud is a paid API. So
if you want to use real data, you can follow
the steps in this course, but actually pay
for an account and use a real API token. What
we'll be using instead is we will be using
a sandbox API token which provides random
data, but it's also free. So what that means
is you can you can do all the normal things
that you can with the IRS code API, but the
data will be randomly generated. So we may
see some interesting results because of that.
The second thing that is different is that
we will not actually be executing trades in
this course. Now, the reason why that is,
is because many of the people who take this
course will be using different custodians
to execute their trades. And each one of those
custodians will have a different API infrastructure.
So I wanted to make this course as widely
applicable as possible. So what we're going
to be doing instead is we're going to be imagining
that we work at a firm where our traders expect
us to generate Excel documents and send them
to them to execute trades. So the output of
each of these three strategies will be an
Excel document that has the the name of each
companies that need to be purchased and the
number of shares of each one of those companies
that the trader needs to purchase. So we won't
be executing trades, but instead, we'll we'll
be generating order sheets to send to our
imaginary traders further down the line. And
just to reiterate that second point, we're
gonna be saving these recommended tricks to
Excel files, which could then be sent to the
traders afterwards. Alright, so now that we
have a bit of a high level understanding of
the algorithmic trading landscape, it's time
to talk about API basics. configuration. So,
to start, let's discuss what is an API. API
is an application programming interface. And
you probably aren't familiar with that if
you've ever heard the term API before, but
that doesn't actually tell you what it does.
I think the easiest way to understand what
an API is, is, it's a way for your software
to interact with and potentially control someone
else's software. So in this case, we're gonna
be using the IE x cloud API. And what we're
going to do is use their API to access their
database of financial data and import it into
our Python script. So like I say, API's allow
you to interact with someone else's software
using your own code. And in this course, we're
going to use the IRS code API to gather stock
market data to make investment decisions.
And to provide you a quick example of what
that looks like. Here's a code snippet. So
this is a cell from a Jupyter Notebook that
has four lines, you can see on the first line
that we declare a symbol AAPL, and that is
the stock symbol for Apple on the NASDAQ exchange.
On the second line, we're creating a string
called API URL that has some interpolated
values that interpolate in the symbol and
our AI x cloud API token token. And on the
third line, we're using the requests library
of Python to provide a GET requests to that
API URL. And then, on the last line, we're
just printing the data that gets returned.
Now, this is kind of a lot. And if you don't
fully understand this, not to worry, you will
see this in a lot more detail when we actually
build the projects for this course. So that's
kind of what an API call looks like. And,
broadly speaking, in this course, we're only
going to be using GET requests to gather data
from the IRS code API. Now, if you've never
used an API before, there's many different
ways you can interact with them. But there's
four major ones. And I'm going to show you
briefly some of the other ways to interact
with an API right now before we proceed through
this course. So get requests allow you to
get data from the API. And that's what we'll
be using in this course. An alternative is
a POST request. And that is a method for adding
data to the database that's exposed by the
API. So it gives a request allows you to get
data from the API and a POST request allows
you to push data to the API. a pull request
allows you to add and overwrite data in the
database that's exposed by the API. Now you
can think of a POST request as a create only
request. And you can think of a put request
as a create or replace request. So there's
a slight difference there. And but even though
it's a small difference, it's an important
difference, because that's kind of a common
source of bugs for software developers. And
the fourth kind of important type of API call
is a delete, which, as it name implies, it
deletes data from the API's database. So to
provide a quick summary of this section, we're
going to be using exclusively GET requests
in our course. But there's three main types
of requests that you should understand those
are post, put, and delete. Now, like most
software concepts, API's are best learned
through rigorous practice. Because of that,
here is a URL that you can use to get a long
list of public API's that are great practice
for you to interact with API's. Now, I would
probably recommend if you've never used an
API before to proceed through this course,
that will give you a base fundamental understanding
of how to work with API's. And then once that
course is done, you can go to this public
URL and practice with some other API's that
are of interest to you personally. So this
is not something for you to look at right
now. But it's a good resource for you to head
later on. Alright, so now that you have a
high level understanding of the course configuration
and some API basics, let's move on to talking
about our equal way s&p 500 fund. So if you've
never heard of it before, the s&p 500 is the
world's most popular stock market index. And
many investment funds are benchmarked to the
s&p 500. That means that they seek to replicate
the performance of this index by owning all
of the stocks that are held in the index.
Now, if you've never really researched how
stocks are added to the s&p 500, there's a
bit of a there's a committee process and some
some sophistication there. But the easiest
way to understand it is that the s&p 500 broadly
covers the 500 largest companies in the United
States. So if you own the s&p 500 index fund,
you basically own the 500 largest companies
in the US. Now aside from the fact that it
owns the 500 largest companies, one of the
other most important characteristics of the
s&p 500 is that it is market capitalization
weighted. Now, market capitalization is just
a finance term, that means basically size.
So coming up with a large market capitalization
just means that it's a large company. And
what this means is that larger companies get
a correspondingly larger weight in the s&p
500 index. For the first product of this course,
we're going to build an alternative version
of the s&p 500 index fund that provide that,
that assigns the same way to each company
in the index. So instead of Apple having a
very big way and best by having a small way,
every company will have the same weight. So
that's going to be the first project of this
course. And the second project we are going
to build a quantitative momentum screener.
Now, momentum investing means investing in
assets that have increased in price the most.
To help you understand let's kind of go through
a quick example. Imagine that you have the
choice between investing in two stocks that
have had the following returns over the last
year. Apple has stock has gone up 35% and
Microsoft stock has gone up 20%. A momentum
investing strategy would suggest investing
in Apple because of its higher recent price
return. There are many other nuances to momentum
strategies, including the concept of high
quality momentum. And that basically means
all else being equal, you would want a stock
that has steadily increasing price rather
than no price change for a while, and then
a large jump at the end. But we'll explore
those when we actually build our quantitative
momentum strategy later in this course. The
third project we're going to build is a quantitative
value screener. Now, value investing just
means investing in stocks that are trading
below their perceived intrinsic value. So
if you kind of want to make a very simple
analogy, value investing is kind of the idea
of buying $1 for 75 cents, and hoping that
you can sell it again for $1 later. So value
investing is a very popular investing strategy
because many of the world's best historical
investors like Warren Buffett, Seth Klarman,
and Benjamin Graham have employed the strategy.
Creating algorithmic trading investing strategies
relies on a concept called multiples and multiples
are simply a way that investors use to estimate
how valuable a company is. So to be more specific
multiples are calculated by dividing a company's
stock price by some measures of the company's
worth, like earnings or assets. So three examples
of multiples that are used in value investing
are the price to earnings ratio, the price
to book ratio, and the price to free cash
flow ratio. Now, as the name implies, the
price to earnings ratio is calculated by dividing
a company's stock price bytes earnings per
share, the price to book value ratio is calculated
by dividing a company's stock price by its
book value per share. And the price to free
cash flow ratio is calculated by dividing
a company's stock price by its free cash flow
per share. So lots of different ways you can
calculate multiples, but those are kind of
three, three of the most important ones Anyway,
now, each of the individual multiples to us
by value investors has its pros and cons.
One way to minimize the impact of any specific
multiple is by using what's called a composite.
Now, a composite is just a average of many
different valuation strategies. So in our
strategy that we build in this course, we're
going to actually be using a composite of
five different value investing metrics. Now,
with all that out of the way, you have a solid
understanding of what we're going to be doing
in this course. And it's time for us to dig
into the first project. So without further
ado, let's do just that. Alright, so it's
now time for us to start tackling our first
project. If you've skipped ahead to this section
of this course, there's a couple of things
that you should do before proceeding. So the
first is to rewind back to the last section
and install all of your dependencies. If you're
a pretty experienced Python developer, the
main dependencies for this course are NumPy,
pandas and XLS x writer. So if you already
have those on your machine, that's fine. If
you've already been following throughout this
video so far, I'm in our algorithmic trading
Python folder that we cloned our local computer,
I have my virtual environment activated. And
what I'm going to do now is launch the Jupyter
Notebook for our first project. So to do that
the command is Python dash M and then notebook.
So this should open up a browser window. And
what we want to do is navigate into the starter
Files folder of the algorithmic trading repository,
and then open up the equal wait s&p 500 dot
i py MB notebook, it should look like this.
So basically, this is what we're going to
be working through in this video. It has some
instructions written in markdown and some
blank code cells. And that's what we're going
to complete as we work through this section.
So let's start with just some background information.
What we're going to do in this project is
to build an equal weight version of the s&p
500 index fund. The s&p 500 is an equal way
or not an equal weight, market weight, market
cap weighted basket of the 500 largest companies
in the United States. Interestingly enough,
it actually has more than 500 stocks in it
because five or so of the largest companies
in the US actually have multiple share classes.
So an example of that is Google it has a Class
A and A Class C share that trade on the stock
exchange. So since alphabet, the company is
included in the s&p 500, both of its stocks
are and because of that, there's usually around
505 stocks in the s&p 500, despite the index
only representing 500 companies. So anyways,
to move on, what we're going to do now is
create a different version of the s&p 500
index fund that doesn't weight the stocks
in the index by market capitalization, but
instead equal weights them so what this means
is that the larger companies in the index
will have less weight than the traditional
version. And the smaller companies in the
index will have a larger way than the traditional
version. So there's some backup information
here just says that the largest one that's
benchmarked to this index is the spdr s&p
500 ETF trust that's commonly known as the
ticker spy spy, which is the ticker that it
trades on on the stock exchange. And that
ETF has more than $250 billion dollars of
assets under management, which is pretty crazy.
Most asset management firms don't have that
much. Hmm. So a really big fun to be sure.
And it says here The goal of this section
of the course is to create a Python script
that will accept the value of your money.
portfolio and tell you how many shares of
each s&p 500 constituent that you need to
purchase to get an equal wave version of the
index funds. So the first thing we need to
do is, you know, like most Python scripts,
this project will rely on a number of open
source software libraries. So we're going
to import those first, we install them to
our local computer in the dependency section
of this course. And now we just need to import
them. And we're going to go through them one
by one here, and I'll briefly explain what
each of these libraries does in case you haven't
haven't worked with them in the past. Alright,
so the first library we're going to import
is NumPy. And the command to do that is important
NumPy. Now NumPy as NP now, NumPy is a numerical
computing library. And it's known for its
fast actually execution speed. And the reason
why NumPy is so fast is because it's actually
a C, or maybe c++ module. So when you call
a Python function in NumPy, it actually executes
the code in a different programming language.
And that programming language is kind of faster
by design. So a NumPy is often used in finance
and other applications to speed up, you know,
basic functions like summing or multiplication,
because it has modules running in a different
programming language that is naturally faster.
So that's NumPy. We're also going to import
pandas, as PD. And pandas is a portmanteau
for panel data, or panel data is I guess,
because it has an S on it. And what pandas
does is it makes it very easy to work with
tabular data in Python. So tabular data is
anything that has rows and columns, you can
think of an Excel spreadsheet as perhaps one
of the most commonly known versions of tabular
data. And pandas is most widely use for its
data structure called the panda's data frame.
And a data frame is just a data structure
that holds tabular data. So pandas allows
you to store data in a data frame, and then
use many different built in pandas functions
and methods to manipulate the data within
that data frame. You'll see lots of examples
about this as you work through this or this
course. And if you're interested in learning
more about pandas Free Code Camp has an excellent
YouTube video on the topic that I would highly
recommend. So that's pandas. And then there's
a couple others we need as well. So actually,
before we move on, one thing that's worth
talking about is these aliases, so we didn't
just import NumPy, we imported NumPy as NP.
And we didn't just import pandas, but we imported
pandas as PD. So why do we do that? This just
save us a bit of typing because we're going
to be often calling functions from these libraries.
So an example would be, let's just run this.
So those imports run and then create a new
code. So if we wanted to create a panda's
data frame that, you know, will just create
an empty one. For an example, if we had just
imported pandas without importing it as PD,
we would have to write panda's dot data frame.
And this call is the class that instantiates
A panda's data frame object. Now, because
we imported it under the alias PD, we can
just do PD dot data frame and it's a little
bit more readable and faster to type. So it's
not necessary to import the under aliases.
I know a few developers who just run pandas
DataFrame. But importing pandas under the
alias PD and NumPy under the alias NP is pretty
common and kind of widely considered to be
a best practice. So that's what we're going
to follow in this course. Alright, let's move
on to importing the other libraries we need.
So the next one is requests. And requests
is a very popular Python library that it's
kind of considered the gold standard for making
HTTP requests. Now, an HTTP request is just
basically an internet request that you can
send to an API to get back some data. And
in this course, we're going to be using the
requests library to execute our API calls
to the IE x cloud API to I guess, receive
our stock market data that we need to calculate
the weightings for s&p 500 index funds, so
the request libraries for HTTP requests. And
that's basically all you need to know about
it for now. The next thing we need to import
is XLS. s writer, this is a library that makes
it very easy to save well formatted documents,
Excel documents from a Python script. So that's
XLS x writer. And the last library we need
is math. So math is just a basic Python library
that provides many of the basic mathematical
functions that you need to, I guess, execute
operations within Python scripts. Alright,
so once you run that code, all of your libraries
will be imported. And the next thing that
we need to do is to import our list of stocks.
Now, like I said, this is going to be a list
of about 500 stocks, maybe a little more if
there's any stocks that are dual listed in
the s&p 501 thing to note about this project
is that since these constituents change over
time, in an ideal world, you'd actually connect
right to an Index Provider or an API, financial
data Data API or something like that. So that
if a stock is added or removed from the s&p
500, then your equal weight s&p 500 strategy
would reflect that now all of the tools that
would provide that information are paid and
this is a free course. So I didn't want to
provide any paid resources in the free course
that kind of defeats the point of it being
free. So what, what I did instead was I saved
a list of the 500 stocks in the s&p 500 into
a CSV file, and you can click this link here
to download that file. So what we need to
do is click that, it'll go into our Downloads
folder, and then we need to move that file
into our starter files, full starter files,
excuse me, we need to move this file into
our starter Files folder so that it can be
accessed by the other files in that directory.
So let's do that now. And then once that's
done, we can import into our Jupyter Notebook.
So open up your finder app, or I guess it
would be finder app or Windows Explorer or
whatever app you have on your operating system
to explore files and navigate to your downloads
folder in one tab. And then in your other
tab, you're going to want to navigate into
that algorithmic trading and Python course.
So here it is. And then specifically, you
want to navigate into the starter file folder
and then drag this s&p 500 stocks dot CSV
into the starter Files folder like that. Okay,
so now that that's done, what we need to do
is save the s&p 500 stocks as a panda's data
frame. And the way to do that is we're going
to assign it to a panda's data frame named
stocks. So stocks equals k dot read CSV, and
then the name of the file. So if you just
type in SP, and then tab, it might autocomplete
there it is. And if it doesn't autocomplete,
just type in the file name. So what is this,
it is a this is a method that lives within
the pandas library that takes in data in the
form of a CSV, and then stores it into a panda's
data frame. So you can verify that by just
doing type of stocks, and this should return
panda's data frame. Yep. And then if you print
it out, it'll actually show the data. So Jupyter
Notebooks have this kind of special feature
where if you type a variable on the last line
of a code cell, it will print it. So this
is what is contained in our, in our panda's
data frame. Like I said, there's actually
505 stocks within this data frame, which means
that there's five stocks that have dual shared
share structures in the s&p 500 at this time.
So that's what we're going to be working with
throughout the rest of this tutorial. The
next thing we need to do is acquire an API
token, like I mentioned in the introduction
to this course, we're going to be using the
IE x cloud API to gather all of our financial
data. And like most API's, they require some
form of authentification before you can pull
data from it. So what we're actually gonna
be using in this course, is the sandbox mode
of the IE x cloud API. And sandbox mode is
a kind of like a play mode, where you can
make sure that all of your API calls work,
but it doesn't actually return real time financial
data. Instead, it returns randomized financial
data. And the reason why sandbox mode exists
is because it allows you to test whether or
not your API calls function properly before
you actually start to use the real API, and
incur data usage as a result. So the easiest
way to to handle this, in my opinion, when
building this course, was to create a secrets.py
file and secrets.py files are files that are
stored in your repository or on the server
that's running this code that doesn't actually
get pushed to GitHub or any kind of remote
Git store. So the reason why is because most
of the information stored in a secret.py file
is sensitive or confidential in some way,
and you just don't want that type of information
stored in a centralized Git repository. So
you'll notice in the Git ignore of this course,
the secrets.py file is actually included in
the Git ignore, which means that if you ever
fork this repository to work on it, and then
push your changes up to GitHub, the information
contained in the secrets.py file doesn't actually
get pushed up as well. So since it's actually
a sandbox API key, it doesn't really matter
in this specific instance, whether the secrets.py
file is exposed. But keep in mind for future
Python courses are anything else that you
work on that you should never share your secrets.py
file with anyone. But this course is kind
of an exception, since we're working with
a sandbox API key. So to start, we're going
to click here. And this will download a secrets.py
file to your downloads folder. Now, you may
get a warning that says something like this,
in my case, it says this type of file can
harm your computer do you want to keep secrets.pi
anyway, and we're going to keep it in and
move it into the same starter Files folder
that we moved our CSV file of stocked into.
So if you open back up your finder, app or
whatever app that you have on your operating
system, you should have your two tabs still
open, you can click and drag the secrets.py
file into the starter Files folder. And then
we need to import our IE x cloud API key into
our script. So what we're going to do for
that is we're going to say from secrets, import,
ie x, and then if you hit tab, it should autocomplete.
It says cannot import I yet have API token.
From secrets. I wonder where that is. usually
done. Okay, so this is equally as. Alright,
so sometimes what happens with these Jupyter
Notebooks is that when you add a file to the
working directory that the Jupyter Notebook
is opening, it actually doesn't recognize
that it's there until you reset the kernel.
So let's try that we're going to say, restart
the kernel. And then we're going to go back
to the top and run all of our code cells from
the start. Awesome. And this time it imported
correctly. So in a lot of cases, I might run
into little hiccups like that when working
through this code. And in some courses, people
edit it out for a more clean experience. But
I would say in the majority of cases, I'm
going to leave them in so that you can see
the debugging process and what I actually
do to fix the problems that I encounter. So
that was a small example of that. You'll see
more as you work through this course. So now
we're going to make our first API call. So
making API calls is a bit of a, an art because
every API works a little bit differently.
And some API's have lackluster documentation.
In this case, the i x cloud API has excellent
documentation. And I'm going to kind of show
you a bit of the documentation as we work
through this section that creates our first
API call. So in this specific case, for the
s&p 500 index fund, there's two things we
need, we need the market capitalization for
each stock and the price of each stock. So
to start, we're just going to do an API call
for one single stock. And then, to generalize
that, for our entire universe of stocks, what
we're going to do is loop over every stock
that's contained in the panda's data frame
that we created earlier, and then run that
same API, call it for each one of those stocks
using a Python for loop. So to start, let's
just create symbol equals. And we're going
to make this a string that is Apple's topic,
which is AAPL. And then on the next line,
we're going to say, what is the API URL? And
that's a good question. What API endpoint
is that, that's what we're gonna find out.
Next. To do that, we're going to navigate
over to the IX, cog documentations. And the
easiest way to find this is just go to is
cloud. Doc's on a Google search. And it's
this first hit here, that is not an ad. So
click through to this. And what this is, is
basically a massive single page resource for
all the possible information that you might
need about the cloud API. ie x cloud has remarkably
good documentation. There are other API's
out there that maybe aren't as commercialized
or are not as mature that won't have documentation
that that's this good. So as you kind of look
through this, keep in mind that this is probably
a better than average documentation page for
an public API. Now, the first thing we need
is the base URL for the API. And what the
base URL is, is it's basically a URL that
will start every HTTP request. And then after
that base URL, you have to add which specific
endpoint that you want to retrieve from the
API. The way most API's work is they only
expose certain data through each endpoint,
which makes things faster if you only need
to retrieve certain data. So one example might
be, if you have the Google Maps API, you might
only want the name of a location. So you would
send coordinates and get back its name, you
wouldn't get back other information like population
or other sorts of things because you only
want name and sending only that limited information
is faster than sending information you wouldn't
meet. So API endpoints are limited in that
respect. But to start, the first thing we
did is the base URL. Now, you can see in this
first block of text called API reference that
the base URL for the API is HTTPS for slash
cloud.ie. x API comm we're actually using
the sandbox mode of this API in this course,
which means that we're not charged for any
usage. But we get randomized that In exchange,
so you could actually use the sandbox mode
to create real investment strategies, but
it's free. And it's still a good way to learn
about how data API's work in general. But
because of that, we can't use this base URL,
what we need to do is a Ctrl F for sandbox.
And if we kind of search through the first
little bit, we find this section called testing
sandbox. It says this is cloud provides all
accounts a free unlimited use sandbox for
testing, every account will be assigned to
test tokens available via the console, all
sandbox API, or sorry, all sandbox endpoints
function the same as production, you only
need to change the base URL and token. So
what does that mean, we need to change the
base URL, which means we need to grab this
instead of the base URL that was provided
earlier. So copy that to your clipboard, move
back to our Jupyter Notebook and paste that
right there. Awesome. So we have our base
URL. The next thing we need to do is figure
out which endpoint we need. And as you can
see from looking at this, we ideally want
to find an endpoint that provides both market
capitalization and stock price. There is one
API endpoint provided by AI x cloud that provides
both of those, but I'm going to show you first
how you would find just any endpoint that
provides one of those metrics and then I'll
show you the input we're actually going to
use so let's start with market capitalization.
Note that is cloud does have this search bar
over here in the top left, but for some reason,
I always just find myself using a Ctrl F instead.
So what we're gonna do here is do market cap
or let's just do market cap not market capitalization
because it's sometimes abbreviated. So what
do we have here for the first its enterprise
value and price to sales. So these are both
metrics that are calculated using market capitalization,
they don't actually give us market capitalization.
So neither of those is what we need. The next
one is actually a true market cap metric.
And this is exactly what we need. But if you
look through the rest of the response attributes
from this API endpoint, this doesn't actually
give you stock price. So we like I said, we
ideally want to find an endpoint that has
both price and market cap. And with a bit
of searching, you would find that the, quote
endpoint provides both of those. So I just
did a Ctrl F for for slash, quote, forward
slash. And this takes us to the information
section about the quote endpoint. Now, every
endpoint description on the IE x cloud API
starts with a section on how to execute the,
the HTTP request for that endpoint. So in
this case, we want to execute a get HTTP request.
And the endpoint is for slash stock, and then
symbol and then forward slash quote. So if
we just copy this, and add this to the API
endpoint that we have in our Jupyter Notebook,
this actually won't work. Because this, you
know, curly brackets symbol thing here doesn't
mean anything in the context of this string.
If we tried to execute this HTTP request as
it is, this will return a 400 error probably.
So what we need to do is we need to transform
this API URL into an F string. Now, an F string,
if you've never used them before, I'll give
you a very brief introduction. So if you have
string equals Free Code, camp is awesome.
And then you said I need to change the values
within this string based on some outside variable.
We will say we'll create a variable called
adjective. And this just describes a word
that we want to call Free Code Camp, we will
say the adjective is superb instead of awesome.
And then we want to pass that adjective variable
where this awesome word is within within the
strength. So the way to do that is you create
an F string, now, as strings are called that
strings, because you simply put an F on the
start of the string. And then this allows
you to interpolate values in so here, curly
brackets, and then we type adjective. Now,
what this string actually stores is Free Code
Camp is superb. And you can test that by printing
the string. Free Code Camp is super now we're
going to use this string functionality to
create our API endpoint. And you're sorry,
yeah, no, to create our API URL. So we're
going to do is we're going to cut this and
just get rid of it. And then here, this already
has the curly brackets that are associated
with an F string. So all we need to do. And
actually, in addition to the curly brackets,
it has the right variable name that we called
here, I think I did that by design, well,
kind of building the code for this course.
So what we're doing is adding an F there.
And then if we print this oops, if we print
this API URL, this should print out this string.
But instead of symbol, it should say a PL
all caps. Perfect. That's exactly what we
need. Okay. The last thing we need to do is
we need to add an appendage to the end of
this API URL that that passes in our API token
to authenticate us through the i x cloud API,
and basically say, this user does have permission
to access this API endpoint. Now the way to
do that is you say, question mark token equals,
and then we're going to use an F string again,
and say, is cloud token that we imported earlier,
if you just type in all caps, ie x and then
hit tab, this will autocomplete for you. Now,
if we print this, oh, sorry, I didn't actually
have a print statement there. If we print
this. This gives us a fully fledged AI x cloud
endpoint that we can pay using the requests
library. So moving on to that, what we need
to do now is execute an HTTP request and store
the results of that HTTP request in some outside
variable, we're going to call that variable
data. And what we need to assign it to is
a requests dot get method. Now, if you've
never used the requests library, that's what
we imported at the top of our script. Here.
It's kind of known as the world's best Python
library for executing HTTP requests. Their
tagline is, their tagline is HTTP for humans.
And I quite like that because it does describe
Well, what they do. So what we need to do
here is just type in request dot get and then
pass in our API URL. Now, if we run that,
what the heck is this data variable? The easiest
way to check is to just do the pipe function
and pass in data. And what it is is it's a
response object, which is contained within
the LA models, module of the requests library.
Now, this response object has many different
things inside of it. And one of the more interesting
ones is the status code. So we can do bank
data dot status code, and I'm gonna hit tab
and see if that autocompletes okay didn't
set out, you know, there it is. And this gives
us a 404. Now, why the heck does it give us
a 404? Clearly I did something wrong here.
Okay, so I just figured it out the error.
And what I missed here was, there's an additional
kind of suffix that needs to get added to
the i x cloud endpoint, called forward slash
stable. Now, why does that exist? If you look
at this section, here, there's two different
naming conventions they can use, you can use
stable or latest stable is kind of the latest
stable API version. As you can see here, well,
latest, you can access the latest API version,
which may be in beta. So basically, stable
is what you want to use if you want to make
sure that your application never breaks. And
latest is what you want to use. If you want
access to the most bleeding edge tech that
might not be fully tested yet. So all we need
to do is go back here, and here type for slash
stable for slash, and then run this. Now we
get a response 200, air response 200 code,
I mean, which means that the HTTP request
was executed properly. And I actually don't
like this format. It's not as accessible as
this status code attribute that we can access.
And the reason I like this better is you can
say, you can test it using equality operator.
So is this equal to 200? True. And that's
kind of an easy way to handle exceptions with
HTTP. But if you say, if it's not equal to
200, oops, you could say if it's not equal
to 200, then do something. Anyways. What we
need to do now is this object is not in any
format that we can really access. So what
we're going to do is we're going to transform
the data that this HTTP request returned to
us into a JSON object, using the dot JSON
method, it actually accept no parameters.
So that's all we need to do. Now, if we print
the data object or the data variable, it gives
us a long JSON type kind of Python dictionary
object that we can use to kind of parse objects
out. Now, if you've never worked much with
Python dictionaries, they're very useful.
I'll make a very quick example here. dictionary
equals now dictionaries are always kind of
created using curly brackets. And what you
can say is say A equals sorry, a colon one,
and B, colon two. So this is a Python dictionary
called dictionary, very creative naming, the
reason why dictionaries are useless because
you can pass in. So these entries here are
called key value pairs. This is the key this
a and this is the value one. The reason why
dictionaries are useful is because you can
pass in the key and it returns the value.
Now, this data variable will behave exactly
the same way. So as an example, if you want
to access this, so this is one key value pair.
And if you want to access the value, which
is AAPL, all you have to do is pass in the
key, which is symbol in square brackets like
that, and this should return an apple perfect.
So the two attributes that we wanted of this
our market capitalization and price. So we're
going to parse that in the next section of
this course. Okay, so what we're gonna do
here is say price equals data. And then where
is the price contained in this, the easiest
way to tell it to do a Ctrl F. And you can
see there's a whole bunch of different price
variables here. The one we want is probably
not calculation price, latest price sounds
right. So that's the latest price provided
by the IETF party API. Now, if you ever see
something like this, and you say, Hmm, I don't
know what latest price means. That's kind
of a bad example. But let's look at something
else in here. That's not as obvious. All right,
this variable extended change. Now what the
heck is extended change the is called documentation.
So that should tell you so if you just copy
that extended change string to your clipboard,
and then go back to the IE x cloud docs, run
a Ctrl F search and type in extended change,
it will take you not just to this JSON object,
but there should be a description below. So
as you can see here, extended change refers
to the price change between extended price
and latest price. So without knowing what
those two means this is kind of meaningless.
But this was just an example to show you how
you can look up the meaning of different data
points within the JSON response in the i x
cloud docs. Okay, so that's how to parse price.
We can print it out and see what the actual
prices 515 28. Now, I actually am not sure
if the is cloud price data is randomized in
our sandbox mode, you can test it pretty easily
by just doing NASDAQ Apple on Google search
for 97. Did it ever get to 515? Okay, so I
don't think that this price is accurate, but
it's actually not far off from the real world
price. So this price data is randomized, but
it's interestingly, quite close to the real
price. So that's how you price out price.
And then for market cap, we'll just say market
cap, Eagles data, and then market cap. And
similarly, you can print market cap. Awesome.
This gives like a, I think this is I'm gonna
divide this by a trillion. That's sorry, that's
only a billion. That's a trillion. So this
gives us a market cap of 2.1 8 trillion, which
again, I think is pretty close to Apple's
real market capitalization. Yeah, so they're
at 2.1 3 trillion. So in both cases, pretty
similar, although, still not exactly correct.
Okay, so that's how you parse a API call.
What we're going to do now is we're basically
going to scale up that process to all of the
stocks within our s&p 500. csv, and then store
all of the responses in a panda's data frame
that we will later save into an Excel file.
So that's what's up next. Alright, so the
first thing we need to do is actually, we're
going to exit out of this Ctrl F box here,
because it was lighting that up and causing
me some eggs. The first thing we need to do
is specify the columns of our panda's data
frame. And to do that, we're going to need
to know exactly what we're building. So we're
going to build a panda's data frame that has
a few columns, it's going to have the ticker
for each stock, it's going to have the stock
price for each stock is going to have the
market capitalization of each stock, and then
it's going to have the number of shares to
buy for each stock. So let's start by specifying
that in a variable called my columns, and
this is just going to be a Python list. And
the entries are going to be thicker. stock
price, market capitalization, hopefully, I
can spell everything right. number of shares
to buy. Okay, so that's the Python list. And
then we're going to do now is create a blank
panda's data frame that has those columns
specified. So to do that, we're going to call
this variable final data frame, because we're
going to this will be the final output of
this program at the end. And to create a panda's
data frame, you use the PD dot data frame,
class instantiation. And inside of this, we're
going to pass in columns equals my columns.
Now, you notice that since this is columns,
I didn't want to call this columns, because
columns equals columns is a bit confusing,
although I think it would work. Let's try
it out. So that does work. I just think it's
quite a bit easier to read. If you say caught
my columns, it kind of removes that repetition.
Okay, so our panda's data frame has been created.
What does it look like? pandas, data frames
are just kind of two ways to print them. As
with most things in a Jupyter Notebook, you
can either use a formal print statement like
that, or you can just list the variable name
as the last line of code. So this is kind
of what it looks like. There's no data in
here right now. So it's kind of empty. But
what we can do is just do create a list of
a list, that's going to be 0000. And this
is kind of how pandas dataframes typically
render. So one of the advantages of not using
a formal print statement is that when you
just list the data frame variable name on
the last line of a code sale, it will render
in this nice format that kind of allows you
to mouse over it, and it changes color. And
it's just a little bit nicer to look at than
the alternative, if you use a print statement
will print like this in just plain text, and
it's not quite as nice. So that's what it
looks like when you print it with plain text.
Actually, you know, the, I'm not a big fan
of it at all. So we'll stick to printing data
frames, specifically like this. So that's
what our data frame looks like. I'm going
to get rid of this line of zeros because that
was just to show you how they render. And
that's what we're going to be working with
moving forward. So what we're going to do
now is I'm going to show you how to append
these data points to this panda's data frame.
So what we're going to use to do that is the
append method. So final data frame dot append.
And then what we need to put in here is a
panda's series that lists all of the entries
in the data frame. So I'll just quickly explain
what a panda's series before a panda's series
is before we move on, so if we add back this
row of zeros to our panda's data frame, like
that. So a panda's data frame is a two dimensional
data structure, which means it has rows and
columns, whereas a panda's series is a one
dimensional data frame. If you've ever worked
much in Python, it's similar to a Python list.
And if you've ever worked with NumPy, it's
similar to a NumPy array just has different
methods and functions associated with it.
But within a panda's data frame, every row
and every column of that data frame is a panda's
series. So, in order to a panda's data to
the bottom of a panda's data frame, that data
needs to be a panda's series. I'll show you
what I mean now. So let's take this row zeros
out and rerun this code cell. And then what
we need to do here is create a panda's series
with PD dot series. And then the pandas series
accepts a Python list. So lots of different
layers here. But what we're eventually going
to work out to is adding a row to this panda's
data frame. So the first thing we're going
to add is the name of the stock, the routing,
which was stored in the symbol variable earlier.
And then we're going to add our price and
market cap variables which we created earlier
price market cap, and then we're going to
add another cell called N A. And what does
this na mean? Well, this last column, the
number of shares to buy, we actually can't
calculate it until we have pulled in all the
metrics for every stock. So what we're going
to do is just start as na now, and later on,
we'll go back in access that data and change
it once we've actually pulled in data for
all of our stocks. So what happens when we
run this code cell? Oh, we missed a comma
in there. Now we get an error can only append
a series if ignore index equals true. So this
is super super common. We're working in pandas,
this ignore index equals true, basically,
almost always needs to be added to the append
method whenever you're appending data to a
panda's data frame. So this is when we get
Whoa, this isn't what we wanted. And as you
can see, all of these columns that we created
have na n values in them, which means not
a number. And then over here, we have the
data that we actually want it now why is that?
It's because we didn't tell the append method,
which columns to add that data to. So what
we need to do to fix that is we need to add
another argument here that says, index equals
my columns. Oh, I missed a comma, I think
No. Oh, so the first sorry, the problem here
is that this index equals my column needs
to be within the pandas series and not within
the panda's data frame. So small difference
there. So when we run this, we're missing
a comma. Again, when we run this, this actually
generates what we want. And so to give a quick
recap, we created a final data frame dot append
method. And then within that final data frame
dot append method, we created a pandas series
that has all of the data points we wanted.
And then we specified index equals my columns,
which tells the append method which columns
to add this data to. And then the last thing
we did was we added to ignore index equals
true, which is kind of necessary whenever
you're appending data to a panda's data frame.
Alright, so what we need to do now is loop
through every ticker in our stocks variable,
and execute an API call for that stock, and
then store the results of that API call in
our panda's data frame. So to start, we're
going to overwrite our old panda's data frame
variable with an empty panda's data frame
that has the same columns as before, so columns
equals my columns, then, we need to create
a for loop that says for stock stock in stocks,
ticker. And to start, let's just print all
of these print stock, what happens? Great.
So we're successfully looping through all
the stocks in that data frame, we can get
rid of that print statement. Now what happens
next, we, we need to actually create an API
call for each stock. So to do that, we'll
scroll up to our old API call cell. And we're
going to copy both of these lines, copy and
then scroll down. Alright, so both of those
are getting copied in here, this needs to
get indented. And then instead of symbol here,
we're going to write stock. R IE x cloud API
token is the same, the data is the same. So
that's all good. Now, one thing to note about
looping through our list of stocks in this
way, is that it's going to be really, really
slow. And the reason why it's slow is because
executing an HTTP request is one of the slowest
things that you can do in Python. So this
slide here, where we actually execute the
request is very, very slow. Later on, we'll
see how to improve the performance of this
code by doing batch API requests that make
it very easy to retrieve information on multiple
stocks with a single API requests. But that's
kind of a more advanced topic. So we're going
to go through with single API requests first.
Okay, so now we need to basically recreate
the append statement that we use earlier.
So final data frame dot append. Inside the
append statement, we need to create a panda's
series of sorry, PD dot series, and inside
that pandas series, we need to create a Python
list. So lots going on here. The first thing
that we're going to add is stock. Now what
is stock stock is the incrementer of this
for loop. So this will actually be the ticker
of the stock we're working with. The next
thing we need to add is data. parsed to latest
price, so this is the same person that we
did before, this will give us our stock price,
which is the second column of the data frame.
The last thing is data, and then market cap,
which is the market capitalization just like
we did earlier. And then just like before,
we will do na for the last row within this
pandas series, function, we need to add index
equals my columns. And then outside of the
pandas series as before, we need to add, ignore
in index equals true. Now, since this is going
to be so slow, like I mentioned, let's just
do this for five stocks and see what happens.
Next, oh, there's a missing comma right there,
run. Great. Now if we print final DataFrame,
what's gonna happen? You think it'll have
information for all five stocks, and nothing's
there. Why is that? Now, the reason why that
is, is because this final data frame dot append
method doesn't actually modify the original
data frame unless you tell it to. So to do
that, the easiest way is to just say, final
data frame. I can't spell today final data
frame equals equals, and then the append statement.
So if we run this, and then run the following,
so we should see a different output. Awesome.
So this is for the first five stocks in our
list of stocks. If we take off this little
argument here, this will take a very long
time to run, let's just see that in action.
I'm going to run this print statement too.
And then while this runs, I'm going to have
a little sip of my coffee and cut out the
rest of this until it's done. Alright, so
as you can see, this is a very long panda's
data frame that has all of the information
we needed. Since it took so long, we're going
to move on now to using batch API calls to
improve the performance of this code. Now,
I x cloud, like most data providers actually
gives you discounts if you use batch API calls,
because it's a lot less load on their infrastructure.
So that's one reason to use them. The fact
that it speeds up your code is another reason
to use them. Overall, if you can use batch
API calls in your scripts, it's generally
a good practice. So pay attention to this
section because it's really important. I x
cloud as a data provider limits their batch
API calls to 100 tickers. So what we need
to do first is find some way to split our
list of tickers up into sub lists of length
100. Now, it's not super intuitive on how
to do that. But basically, what I did just
to show you is I said, how to split a list
into sub lists. And in Python. Awesome, here's
the sorry, that took a bit of time, I had
to skip ahead. But here's the function that
I was talking about. So it's called chunks.
And in the finished files of this course,
you'll see that actually gave credit to this.
It has 3000 uploads, which is pretty crazy,
even for Stack Overflow. So this is what we'll
be using to split our list or our pandas series,
in this case into chunks of size n. So we'll
run that code cell to define this function.
Okay, what we need to do now is use this chunks
function to create a list of lists where every
list is no longer than 100. So to do that,
we'll say, symbol groups that will we'll call
this equals chunks, and then the list we want
to split is stocks, ticker. Now, the reason
why we have to pass this as ticker is because
this is a panda's data frame. And ticker is
the header of the only column. So if we just
did stocks, this gives us the data frame.
If we do stocks at header ticker, that gives
us a series which we can pass into this chunks
function. And everyone say 100. So this gives
us a chunk generator. And to get the actual
lists, we just have to pass it into a list
function. So we'll do that. And it will say
symbol groups, see what that gives us. Okay,
so this gives us a list of lists, or more
specifically gives us a list of pandas series.
So this is from index zero to index 99. This
is from index 100, index 199. This is from
index 200 to 299 300 to 399 400 to 49. At
the end, we have this one that's much shorter,
it's 500 to 504. And that's because there's
505 stocks in the s&p 500. And this just gives
us groups of 100. At most, and since this
one only has five minutes shorter. Okay, so
moving back up, what we need to do now is
make a for loop that lists loops through every
list, or sorry, every panda's series within
that list, executes a batch API call. And
then for every stock in that list, appends
the information from that stock to our final
data frame. So first thing to do is for i
in range, zero to length of symbol groups,
and then print. So what does this give us
this gives us 012345. Now, those are all the
indices This symbol group groups list. So
if we do this, oh, sorry, that's not what
I meant to do print that. This will just print
out all of the lists within our list of lists
called symbol groups. So now what we need
to do is we need to transform all of the stocks
that's in each of those lists into a string,
and that string will be passed into the URL
of the HTTP request that we're executing.
So first, we'll just create an empty list
called symbol strings. And what this is, is
it's going to be a list of strings, where
each string is a comma separated string of
all the stocks in this object. So all we need
to do is use the append method tabbies in
so we're going to do symbol strings, dot 10.
And then what we're going to use is the join
method called on the comma character join,
and then symbol groups. Now, if you've never
used the join method before, basically what
this does is it says, Take all of the elements
of this and join them together by separating
them with this. So to see that in action,
we'll just do print symbol, strings. Strings
at index i. Alright, so here's one example.
Here's another example. And you can tell these
examples apart. Because at the end of the
line, there's a gap. Sorry, this is one example,
I had one extra line there, you can see this
example ends there because there's a gap.
And it starts on the line after this, because
this is the last line of the first example.
So there we have our five lists of symbol
strings, I'm going to comment this out, because
we don't want that printing every time we
run this code. So the next thing we need to
do is create a blank final data frame again.
So we're using the same variable name, which
probably not a good practice, but we're overriding
it each time. So equals P dot data, frame,
and columns equals my columns, you guys know
the drill by now. Now, let's just print out
to make sure that it looks okay. Awesome,
so we can delete this out. Okay, the next
thing we need to do is loop through every
string in our symbol strings object, and then
use that string to execute a batch API request.
So we're gonna use a for loop for this. And
to keep the, the nomenclature pretty simple,
we're going to just say for symbol string,
in symbol, strings. And then we can actually
print these out to make sure that this is
working right. Simple string. Awesome, that
looks good. We're going to take away that
print statement now. And then we need to create
a batch API call URL. And as before, this
is going to be an F string where we pass in
the the base URL of the API endpoint, and
then pass in all of the strings through for
each of these symbol strings into the endpoint
to get 100 to get data for 100 stocks back.
Now, if you've never run a batch API call
through is called before you probably are
unsure how to do this, let's just go to the
docks here and do a Ctrl F for batch and see
what comes up batch requests. Okay. So
So what it says here is that use market to
query multiple symbols, okay, so this is what
we want this stock market. And then, as you
can see, you pass in one of the parameters
as symbols equals a comma separated value
of symbols, and then types equals a comma
separated value of API endpoints that you
want to hit. And then if applicable range
tells you how much data to pull for. And then
at the very end of this, you would pass on
your token as well. Because we're going to
do is oops, did not mean to click that. What
we're going to do is copy this, go back to
our Jupyter Notebook. We're going to pass
that in here for now. And then we're going
to scroll up to our last API call and get
this base URL, including the stable that I
missed earlier. We're going to copy this here.
We're going to delete the double forward slash.
And then we're going to move over to the end
of the API call and change a few things. So
the first thing we're going to do is remove
this last parameter and this range parameter.
We don't need those for the API call that
we're doing. The next thing we're going to
do is remove the chart and news endpoint from
that example, because we don't need them.
Next, we're going to actually remove these
symbols that are hard coded into this, we're
going to do a variable interpolation interpolation
for a symbol string. And then what we're going
to do is move to the very end. And as before,
we can just copy on the IaaS cloud API token
that we had in our original API call. So copy
this scroll. Like down, go to the end of the
string and add it. Awesome. Now, let's just
do for symbol string and symbol string up
to, but not including the first one. And then
we're going to just print this and see what
it gives us. Oh, and I spelt that wrong here,
which I'm going to correct now. And then print
API call URL. Now we're getting an error,
that API call URL is not defined. There's
three L's here. That's why I run that again.
Alright, so this gives us a long URL that
looks okay to me. One really easy way to test
this is to just click on it. It's a 400. Bad
request. I'm not sure why. Stable slash stock
slash bash, let's make sure that that matches,
slash stock market slash batch. Symbols equals
symbol string. Types equals one. Oh, so the
problem here is that when you're passing on
multiple parameters to an API request, so
this first character is a question mark, and
then every successive character that chains
these parameters together needs to be an ampersand.
So we're going to copy this ampersand and
replace this question mark with it. And I
think that should fix the problem. Great.
So this is actually opened in a browser, the
JSON that is going to be returned from this
API request. So now we can do what we did
before, use the requests library to get this
data. So I'm gonna do data equals requests,
dot get, and then that URL. And then as before,
we're going to pass the JSON method onto this.
Actually, before we do that, let's just do
print data dot status code. So returns 200,
which means it's working properly. Now what
we can do is pass the JSON method on to this
data variable. And then we need to parse data
from this. So more specifically, we need to
parse data for every specific stock that's
in this symbol string. Now the way to do this
is just like before, how we use this join
method to join together all of the different
strings that were contained in that list,
you can use the split method to basically
do the opposite. So we can say, or symbol
in symbol, string dot split, and we're going
to split on the comma character. Let's just
print every symbol and see what happens. Awesome.
So it looks like it's successfully looping
through all of the first 100 stocks there.
And what we need to do now is parse the batch
API call for data for every specific stock
in the order that we need, and then append
that data to the panda's data frame. So just
like before, we're going to use the append
method, we're gonna say final data frame,
equals final data frame, dot append. And then
in here, we're going to specify that it's
a panda's series. And inside the pandas series,
we're going to pass in a Python list. So all
of that is exactly what we did before. So
I kind of skipped over it. And then here,
we're going to pass in the same for variable,
so symbol, and then price, which will be data.
And then we have to do actually multiple levels
of parsing this time, because not only do
we have to parse the metric for that stock,
but we also have to parse the batch API call
to get the information for that specific stock.
So here's how you do that. We do symbol, and
then quote, so this is the stock and then
the endpoint, and then we need to parse out
the metric latest price. And we can follow
similar logic here to get
the market capitalization. So market cap,
and then just like before, we are going to
not specify the last column, we will calculate
that later. Let's run this and see what happens.
Actually, I'm going to add one last line to
this set print scalar data frame. All right,
let's run this and see what happens. Type
error can only append a series. This is that
ignore index specification that I mentioned
earlier. So that needs to get added in right
here. And actually now that I think about
it, inside this pandas series class instantiation,
we need to pass in index equals my columns.
Alright, let's try this. Invalid index index
and ignore index equals true. I'm missing
a comma there. One more time. Awesome. So
as you can see, we've successfully upended
the ticker, the stock price, the market capitalization
and the number of shares to buy the only other
Change we have to make this code sell is to
remove this little appendage right here, that
made it loop only over the first instance.
So now when we run this, it will actually
loop over every single string and add every
stock within our list to our panda's data
frame. So let's try that. Awesome. As you
can see, that was way, way faster than using
individual API calls for each stock, the other
one took probably two or three minutes. And
that was only a few seconds. So huge improvement
there. I mean, in theory, if all the API requests
take the same amount of time using batch API
call should make it 100 times faster because
it does one call for every 100 stocks, but
anyways, much faster in any case, and it looks
like we go all the way from A to Z, all the
data looks okay, so we're ready to proceed
to calculating the number of shares to buy.
Alright, so the reason why we left this calculating
the number of shares to buy step until later
in the script is because I want this to actually
work regardless of how big your portfolio
is. So how we're going to handle that is,
we're going to create a Python input that
says how large is your portfolio, and then
based on what you tell Python, it will calculate
the number of shares to buy accordingly. So
to do that, we're going to use pythons input
function. And more specifically, we're gonna
say, portfolio size is equal to input. And
then inside this input, it accepts a string.
And that string is kind of what question you
want, Python asked you. So here's how it's
the looks, enter the value of your portfolio.
Now if we run this, you can see there's an
input that says enter the value of your portfolio,
we can write, you know, $1,000. And then we
can access that value later on in the script.
So now, if we do, you know, portfolio size,
it'll print out 1000. Note that this is actually
a string. So that fact that this accepts a
string is actually something we need to make
sure we handle because since it's a string,
you could say I don't have a portfolio. And
that would actually kind of break the rest
of this script, because it's going to try
to do mathematical operations on this string,
which is obviously impossible. So what we
need to do is create kind of a try accept
statement. So if you're not familiar with
try accept, basically, the way these work
is, try except, you could say, try to do this.
And if this doesn't work, it will do whatever
is specified here. So one example would be
like, if you say, two plus n, and is not defined,
so then it will print out, you know, and is
not fine. We're going to comment this out,
so it doesn't run. Now if we run this, it
should print n is not defined. Awesome. Now,
if we say two plus two, it will doesn't print
it. But if we wrapped it in a print statement
would four, okay, so we're going to use this
same logic to handle the fact that people
might not put number variables into this portfolio
size input. So the first thing to do is uncomment.
This, the next thing we need to do is to try
to kind of handle our input as a float variable.
So to do that, we're just gonna create a variable
called Val. And we're going to say that's
equal to float, portfolio size. Now, this
float function is basically going to take
this portfolio size variable and try to force
it to be a float. So if we say, print vow,
actually, no ignore that we're going to do
is put that in here and say, print vow. And
then for this, except we're going to say,
Please enter an integer. Now, if we put in
a sentence will say, again, I don't have a
portfolio returns, please enter an integer.
Now, this broad try accept statement is actually
not good. And the reason why is because this
will react regardless of what type of error
is happening. So what we need to do to make
sure that it only handles this specific type
of error that we're trying to address is we
need to try to do this and kind of force an
error. So we'll put a string in there. And
then as you can see, the type of error that's
created is a value error. So we need to basically
change this script so that it only reacts
to value errors instead of reacting to all
types of errors. And the way that you do that
is you put the type of error right here and
run this again and see that it does handle
this properly. Okay, so what we want to do
now is instead of just handling this, instead
of just handling this and saying please enter
an integer, we need to actually make it redo
this. So how does this look? Please enter
an integer. All we want to do is say in here,
enter the value of your portfolio. And then
above this, we want to tell them exactly why
they're getting this input prompt again. So
we're going to print and say, That's, please
double brackets, that's not a number, and
then four slash, and so that'll create a new
line, please. Please try again. And then now
equals float. Awesome. So just to recap, we
try to get the value of someone's portfolio
using the input function. In the first step
of the try accept block, we try to force that
that that input ID value to be a flow variable
and assign it to a variable called Val. If
that doesn't work, because of a value error,
then we print down, that's not a number, please
try again. And then we prompt them to enter
the value of their portfolio again, and then
we, we force it to be a strongly typed float
again. Now, one interesting thing to note
about this is that if you do it twice, string,
and then string, it will still trigger a value
error. So you need to kind of rely that the
user of this script is going to be like, I
guess, astute enough to not enter a string
twice. So it might look something like this,
they go and say, enter the value of your portfolio
$1,000. And they say, That's not a number,
please try again. So then you say, Oh, it's
$1,000. And then you can proceed through the
rest of the script. Okay, so now that we've
accepted the number from the user of this
script, we need to actually use that number
to base our share calculations on now since
this is equal weight, every stock in the portfolio
will have the same position size and position
size is kind of just a fancy financial term
that says how much money you're going to invest
in each stock now, Center's 505. Stocks, an
easy example would be if your portfolio is
$505,000, all you would do is invest $1,000
in each stock. So as you can see, the easiest
way to calculate that is just to say, position
size, is equal to the value divided by the
length of any column from the final data frame.
So in this case, we'll just do final data
frame dot index, and then print position size.
This says, We made a small portfolio here
of $1,000. So it's just you know, saying give
us $1.98 in each stock, let's use something
more reasonable, like a million dollars. Awesome.
So now saying invest, you know, $19,000 in
each stock, that sounds about right to me,
Oh, hang on, is this a million or 123, that's
10 million. So $19,000 in each stock, or almost
20,000 makes sense for a $10 million portfolio.
Alright, so we have the position size now.
Now we need to calculate how many shares of
each stock need to be purchased to get to
that position size in that stock. So let's
take an easy example. Apple stock price is
about $500. Right now. So if we wanted, you
know, number of Apple shares to buy, you would
just say, position, size divided by Apple
stock price, which is $500. ish. And then
you can print the number of Apple shares.
And in this case, it says, okay, buy 39.6
Apple shares. Now, this introduces an interesting
concept in that a lot of places do not support
fractional trading, which means that you can
buy a portion of a share, you can only buy
whole shares. So you can buy 39 shares, or
you can buy 40 shares, but you cannot buy
39.6 shares. So how do we handle this? Well,
it's tempting to just say, let's round it
to the closest number up or down. But what
might happen then is that if you are rounding
up more integers than you're rounding down,
you'll actually end up buying more stock than
you have money for. And that is not a good
thing, you would get to the end of your allocation
and say, oh, man, I don't actually have enough
money left over to get to my position size
target on this stock. So because of that,
we actually have to round each of these down.
And that's where that math module that we
imported earlier comes in. So math dot floor
is pythons round down function. So if we print
this, that should give us 39. Oh, shoot, math
is not defined. I think it might be lowercase
n. Yeah, math floor. So that gives us 39.
Okay, so this is kind of like the logical
intuition on how to do this, we now need to
programmatically loop through every row of
our panda's data frame, and actually apply
this logic to the number of shares by column.
Now to do this, I'm just going to comment
that out because it'll be useful for us later.
Alright, so we're going to say for i in range
from zero, and then we needed to go to the
last row of the data frame, and the easiest
way to do that is just say the length of any
row within the data frame. What I typically
use is final data frame index. As you can
see, this logic is actually basically what
I used here as well. So Let's use this and
then just print everything in here. All right,
this goes from goes from zero to 504. Let's
just make sure that adds up with the data
frame we clicked earlier or printed earlier,
I should say, it goes from zero to 504. Awesome.
Now, we need to access this cell in each row
of the data frame. The easiest way to do that
is using the LLC method. So what we're gonna
do is, say final data frame, dot LLC. And
this is a basically like an easy row column
way of accessing data in pandas. So for the
row, we're going to say I and for the column,
we're going to say, the number of shares to
buy. And let's just print this to see if it
prints a bunch of Ma, because that's what
it should print. Awesome. So we're correctly
accessing the data. Now we need to actually
assign the data. So to do that, you can just
use the equality operator and then say, math
dot floor. And then we need to do basically
this calculation here, position size divided
by the stock price. So we'll say, position,
size divided by now what are we going to do
for stock price? Do we have to execute another
API call and pull that data from IE x again,
we actually don't and the reason why is because
that data is already stored in the panda's
data frame. So we can take similar logic to
this LFC method here and put that there, paste
it, and just change this to stock. Price.
Oh, this tab, autocomplete is not working.
So if we run this, what happens? It ran correctly.
Let's do this again, and print the data frame
to see if it looks okay. Awesome. So as you
can see, it correctly kind of shows the number
of shares to buy here. One easy way to fact
check this, well, there's a couple things
you knew, the first thing is to say, Okay,
this apple stock price is close to the 39
that we calculated earlier. So that's a good
sign. Another thing you can do is say, look
at two stocks that have different stock prices,
and the one that has the higher stock price
should be recommended to buy less shares than
one that has a lower stock price. So let's
just use the first two rows of this data frame
as an example, you can see that for this stock
with ticker a, it costs $100 to buy it and
you're buying 197. And then the second stock
has a much lower stock price. And because
of that, you have to buy many more shares
to actually reach your target position size.
Now, that kind of all looks good. So we can
move on, I'm going to take away this comment
code and just tidy this up a little bit. And
we can proceed to the next cell. All right.
So this brings us to the last section of this
project, which is to save our panda's data
frame into an XLS. x file for non technical
users to access to excel. So the big idea
here is that we did all the work in a Python
script, you could schedule the script to run
periodically, and then the output would be
sent to your trading team to actually buy
and sell stocks in response to the output.
So to do this, we're going to use the XLS
x writer library for Python. Now, oops, the
new mean remnant. If you remember, at the
start of this project, many lines of code
ago, we actually imported this here. So it's
actually in our script already, we just need
to use it now to save our data frame as an
Excel file. Now XLS x writer is an excellent
package and offers an insane amount of customization.
But the trade off for this is that the library
can seem a bit complex to new users, I'm going
to do my best to explain it well throughout
this section. And because of that, this might
be a bit long. So if this seems easy, or you've
used that asset, if this seems easy, or you've
used XLS x writer in the past, you can feel
free to speed up the speed here a bit or skip
ahead. Alright, so the first thing we need
to do is actually initialize our XLS x writer
object. And the way that we do that is by
saying writer equals PD dot XML writer. And
then here, we need to pass in the file name
that we want to save to in this case, we're
going to do recommended trades dot XLS x.
And then we need to specify the engine, which
is XLS x writer. Now, let's break this down
a little bit to kind of describe what's going
on here. As you can see, the class that we're
initializing here is from the pandas library,
and not actually from XLS x writer. And the
reason why that is, is because since pandas
deals with tabular data, and so much tabular
data is actually saved to Excel files. They
have a very tightly coupled integration. And
it actually kind of is easiest to initialize
a new writer object from pandas rather than
XLS x writer and kind of by default, you always
save these objects to a variable called writer.
It allows you to reuse your code without having
to change the object name later and it's kind
of just a best practice. So when I say writer
equals P dot x, x l writer, and then this
is the filename that we want to save to and
then the engine equals XLS x writer. It may
seem a bit redundant, but this library can
also be used to Save XML file. So we have
to actually specify that we want to work in
Excel. So that's the first thing we need to
do. The next thing we need to do is actually
to pass our panda's data frame into this object
in specify which tab of the Excel file we
want it to be saved to. So to do that, we
do final data frame.to Excel. And then the
first thing we pass in is that writer object.
The next thing we pass in is the name of the
tab we want it to be saved to so we'll say
recommended trade again. And the last thing
we pass in is an index equals false argument.
Alright, so our object has been created. The
next thing we need to do is to create the
format's we need for our XLS x file. Now,
earlier when I said that this library can
be confusing or complicated to new users,
this is where it gets really, really complicated.
Formatting Excel files with XLS x writer is
a science and there's a lot to it. But I'm
going to try to keep things simple here. And
hopefully, you guys won't run into any hiccups.
First things we're going to do is create,
I guess, two variables that specify the color
scheme for our Excel sheet. And then we will
reference those variables in all the formats
that we create later on. So that if we want
to change one color, it will be reflected
across all the different formats that we create
later, instead of hard coding them in and
having to change many different instances
have a specific color. So specifically, what
we're going to create is a background color
variable and a font color variable. So background
color, and these are just going to be empty
strings for now. font color. Alright, so what
goes in here, these actually store the HTML
hex codes for the very first for the colors
that we want to select. So I'm going to use
two colors that kind of match the style of
the Free Code Camp website, I really like
it, it's command line chic, and very modern.
So we're just going to follow that to make
things easy, the background color is going
to be zero, a zero, a two, three, and the
font color is going to be at six s. Alright,
so that's that. Now we need to actually create
a few different formats that we will be referencing
when we actually apply the format's to our
cells in our Excel sheet later on. So as you
can see up here, we need a string format $1
format with decimals, $1 format without decimals
and an integer format. So let's start with
string format. And then what we're going to
do here is create a writer dot buck dot add
format method. Inside this add format method,
we have to create a dictionary. And this dictionary
specifies the format of the cells that are
going to have this applied to them later.
So what goes in here, there's three main attributes
on color, background, color, and border. Now
each of these should actually be strings,
I'm going to fix that indenting issue. Since
this is a dictionary, what is going on, I
find the indenting on Jupyter Notebooks leaves
a lot to be desired. Since this is a dictionary,
these should be strings. And we have to add
colons to each one. All right, so the font
color is going to be font color. And this
font color variable is what we defined up
here, this background color is going to be
background color. And this border is going
to be one, this just means that a solid border
around each one now. This is our first one,
let's run this code to make sure it works
properly. Awesome. Now we need to basically
template off of this and create a few other
formats. So we have string format, and we
need to name the other ones that we described
before this code cell is a string format,
dollar format, and in integer format, now,
all of these are going to share the same attributes
that the string format specified, we just
need to add a few things to each one. So for
dollar format, we need to specify a number
format attribute like this. And the way that
this works is actually pretty easy. You just
pass in a number with zeros in it templated
the way that you want it to be formatted.
So in this case, it will look like that. And
then we will do the same thing for the integer
format. So num format and then we're just
going to say zero. Awesome. Let's run this
code cell to make sure there's no syntax errors.
Excellent. Alright, so now we need to apply
the format that we just created to our XLS
x file. And this is like a big complicated
so what I did here was I actually provided
an example and we can kind of use this to
template on for all of the columns in our
sheet. So what we need to do is say writer
dot sheets, and then parse out the recommended
trade sheet from an object. And then we use
the set column method on that item to success.
To find information about the column we're
doing now, we're gonna do this one by one
first, and then we're going to kind of put
everything into a loop because it'll be a
bit more efficient on code and much more readable.
So let's start with column A. And you actually
can't just put a, you have to put a through
a like that. So that tells you the column.
And then we need to specify the column width,
let's do 18 pixels. And then you need to say
which format you want to apply to it. Column
A is our ticker format. So we need string
format, it's not a number. Now, if you run
that, it returns zero. And that basically
tells you that it ran properly, the way to
actually see this in action is you need to
actually save your writer object. Now, to
do that, you say writer dot save. And then
if you go to your working directory, where
you're running through this, you should be
able to open up your recommended trades. Excel
file and see that the first column has actually
been formatted properly. So let's do that
for all the other columns. And then we can
change a couple things to make it formatted
better. So how to do this, we'll just copy
this a few times and change the letter four
times to be specific. So this should be B
for me, this should be C for C, and this should
be d3, D. Now let's run this and see that
what happens to the Excel sheet. Only one
was formatted. Why is that? These? Oh, I think
we have to go back here and re initialize
this. Alright, let's try now. Awesome. So
as you can see, the columns are being formatted
properly, but the headers aren't. Just so
you know, we're gonna solve that later. It's
not something that I'm ignoring. But we will
solve that in a few cells. So what we need
to do now is we're going to simplify this
by making two loops. And each of those loops
is going to work with this column format,
a dictionary that we're going to create. So
let's create column format, and make a dictionary.
Now what this dictionary is going to be is
it's going to have a key for each column.
So A, B, C, and D. and the value for each
column is going to be a list inside that list,
the first item is going to be the title. And
the second item is going to be which format
we want to apply. format. It's a ticker string
format, and then stock price, dollar format,
comma, their market cap. And the last one
is going to be number of shares to buy and
integer format. So let's run that sudden,
that cell ran correctly, which tells you that
that dictionary is formatted properly. And
now we're ready to start building a couple
of loops to do all of the work that we did
up here, but automatically, so the loop that
we're going to be building specifically is
going to loop through every key in that dictionary.
So when you say for column in column, format
stuff key, if you've never used the, the keys
method to iterate through a dictionary before,
it basically just returns all of these. So
we print the call and it should print ABCD.
Yep. Now what we need to do is create a writer
dot sheets, recommended trades dot set column,
we're basically doing all the work we did
up here. So set column. Here, we're going
to do an F string that interpolates in column,
column. So this would just be like for column
A would be a colon a, we're going to Ms string.
And then we're gonna do 18 pixels wide. And
then we're going to do column format, add
column. So this will be this dictionary at
key A. So this would return this list. And
then we need the second element of this list.
And since Python is zero index, three parts
one. Great, so that runs properly. Awesome.
So if you if we redo all of this to Okay,
here's we're going to do, we're going to comment
out this. We're going to put a writer dot
save method there. And then we're going to
go back to the start reinitialize, our writer
object and run all this code. Awesome. Let's
take a look and see what our Excel file looks
like. Great, so everything's being formatted
properly. In that loop. Our code is a lot
cleaner, it's easier to read. It's a big improvement.
Now what we need to do is handle these and
columns in XLS x right are kind of hard to
deal with, what I always do is I just overwrite
them. So writer dot sheets, recommended trades.
And then I do dot, right. And this right method
you pass in, what information you want stored
in the cell, and what format you want to apply
to that cell. You also need to specify the
location of the cell. So here's what we're
gonna do renew a one, we're gonna say ticker.
And we're gonna say string format. Now, if
we go back to the top again, reinitialize
this and run through the rest of this, and
go back to our cell file. The first cell is
formatted properly. So now we just need to
do the same thing for stock price market capitalization
and number of shares to buy. Let's go back,
easiest way to handle that is to just copy
and paste. So this will change to a one B
one note sorry, that should be a one or sorry,
a two or B one. B one, Okay, perfect. All
right, a one, B one, c one, D one. And this
will be stock price. With dollar format. This
will be market capital realization with dollar
format. And this will be number shares to
buy with integer format. Alright, as before,
we're going to go back to the top, we're going
to reinitialize, this Excel writer object,
run our code to the very end, and then take
another look at our Excel file. Awesome. So
everything looks formatted properly, the only
thing that might be worth improving is to
widen this a little bit. But I mean, anyone
who has an auto format or for Excel will be
able to handle that pretty easily. Alright,
so this violates the programming principle
of do not repeat yourself, this is very, very
loopable. So we're going to create another
loop here, that basically does this logic.
So Alright, so we're going to add this in
here. And what we need to do is, say, column
here, and convert this to an F string. So
as this loopster through this will go from
a one to B one to C one to D one. And then
we need to capture this value here. So it's
going to be column, column, format. So this
is the dictionary. And then we parse out columns.
So this is the value of a key value pair,
and then we want zero, and this will be the
first entry of the list, that is the value
in the key value pair. So that's this, and
then this needs to get replaced with the second
entry of the list. Easiest way to do that
is to just copy this and replace the zero
with a one. So let's go there, one. Alright,
as before, we're going to scroll all the way
up to the top reinitialize, our writer object,
move all the way through to the end. Let's
open this up and see if everything works.
Okay, great. So this is the final output of
the first project from this algorithmic trading
and Python course. It says here that the last
step is to save the writer output that's actually
this line. So we're already done. And just
like that, you built your first algorithmic
trading project in Python, I hope you had
fun, the next few projects are gonna be even
more often, you're going to learn a lot more.
So I hope you enjoy the rest of this course.
And kudos to you for sticking through it so
far. All right. So welcome to the second project
for this course, where we're going to build
a quantitative momentum strategy, what we
need to do to start just like before is we
need to open up our Jupyter Notebook. So here,
I'm here in my terminal in my home root directory,
and what I need to do is navigate into my
dev folder. And within that dev folder, I
need to navigate into algorithmic trading
in Python, which you can see here auto completed
for me, so we'll move into there. And now
that we're here, we need to activate our virtual
environment. So you'll remember from before
that the command to do that is source and
then V and V four slash bin forward slash
activate. If you look to the left and your
terminal command, here, you can see that that
V and V in parentheses there shows that the
virtual environment has been activated correctly,
and none of the virtual environment has been
activated. You can watch it with Python bash,
and a notebook that will launch a Jupyter
Notebook. Now, one thing that I'm not sure
I mentioned before is that you can deactivate
a virtual environment by simply typing deactivate.
And if you try to launch a Jupyter Notebook
with this, it will actually fail because it'll
say no module named notebook. So we need to
reactivate our virtual environment and then
launch our Jupyter Notebook. This will start
the server in our browser and we can get started.
Just like before, we're going to want to navigate
into starter files and then open up the second
project this time, which is quantitative momentum
strategy. So let's open that To get started.
Alright, so just like before, this Jupyter
Notebook starts with a bit of background information.
So it says momentum investing means investing
in the stocks that have increased in price
the most. For this project, we're going to
build an investing strategy that selects the
50 stocks with the highest price momentum.
From there, we will calculate recommended
trades for an equal weight portfolio of the
stock. So, this project will combine a lot
of the stuff that we used in the last section.
So that repetition will help you remember
what we actually just did, because I know
that that last project actually contain a
lot of stuff. And then we're going to build
on top of that by not just equal weighting
a already selected universe of stocks being
the s&p 500. But we're going to actually select
a subset of those stocks based on their momentum
characteristics. So let's get started by first
importing some libraries. Alright, so just
like before, we're gonna need NumPy, and we're
gonna import that as NP, we're gonna need
pandas, and we're gonna import that as PD.
So as a quick recap, NumPy is the best Python
library for numerical computing and pandas
is a Data Science Library that makes it very
easy to work with tabular data in Python,
you'll remember that we worked a bunch of
the PD dot data frame structure in the last
project. And we'll do the same thing in this
project. We're also going to need the requests
library for making HTTP requests, we're going
to need the math library for performing some
basic math functions. And we're going to need
the Sai pi library. Actually, we're not going
to need the whole library, we're just going
to need the stats library from Sai pi imports
that. And the last thing that we need is the
XLS. x writer library, which we saw in the
last section allows us to easily format and
save Excel files from a Python script. Now,
we've seen all of these before except for
the sci fi stats module. And what this does
is it makes it very easy to calculate percentile
scores. So we'll see later on in this project
that what we're actually going to do is we're
going to gather and parse momentum momentum
metrics for all of the stocks in our universe.
And then we're going to calculate percentile
scores for those momentum metrics, then we're
going to rank the stocks on those percentile
scores, and we're going to select the 50 stocks
that have the highest average percentile score
across a broad basket of momentum metrics.
So if you haven't seen side by stats, it's
pretty easy. We're just gonna use the percentile
score calculation feature of it. And yeah,
so that's it for our libraries, let's move
on to importing our list of stocks. So actually,
we should run this code sale first. Alright,
so now that our imports have been done for
our open source Python libraries, we need
to actually import our list of stocks. Now.
We also need to import our API token, we did
both of these steps in the last project as
well. So before I actually code this out,
try to go through and without looking at your
last one, figure out how to import your list
of stocks into a panda's series and figure
out how to import your API token from your
secrets file. So cut here and try to do that
before proceeding. Okay, I hope you had success
doing that if you didn't, the command to import
your list of SOS PT, underscore, sorry, dot
read underscore CSV, and then type in your
list of stocks. Now, it should autocomplete
if you just type in SP. And then you can print
it out to make sure it looks okay. Just like
before, it has all 505 stocks in the s&p 500.
And then for the secrets file, we went from
secrets import. And if you hit tab, you can
see that the is how the API token actually
shows up here. So that is great. We can run
this code cell to get both of those imported,
and we can move on to make our first API call.
Now, this is where this project will start
to be quite a bit different than the last
project that we worked through. Because we're
actually going to be pulling different stock
market information from the IE x cloud API.
More specifically, instead of trying to pull
price and market capitalization, we're going
to be pulling price in one year stock return.
So to do that, we're going to go to the i
x cloud docs. Oops, let's try and keep this
all in one browser window. There we go. So
I x docs. And we're gonna go here, it's usually
the first non Add Entry in a Google search.
And then we're going to run a Ctrl F and see
what kind of return metrics we can actually
find in here. Okay, so return is clearly not
a good thing to search for, because it gives
341 heads and you can see why that is, is
because a lot of these will say most endpoints
return. So the fact that endpoints can return
something in stocks can also return a percentage
is not good. What if we just type it in momentum?
These are all more complex momentum metrics
than we need. Okay, what if we type in price
return? Zero if we type in price return with
no space. Okay, once we type in year return,
this might be REST API endpoint that gives
us a one year return or something like that.
Still nothing. What if we do performance?
Okay, this gives us 21. sector performance.
As you can see, it's not always super straightforward
on how to find these. Okay. So now I'm searching
through return again, it is a lot of hits.
But I feel like it's going to be near the
top of this documentation page. Okay, so this
looks promising. This is a historical prices
endpoint. And this would actually allow you
to get the job and you could pull in historical
prices for let's say, one year, and use the
today's price divided by the price one year
ago, and then subtract one and that will give
you your one year price return. However, I
know that I x actually calculates this metric
and I separate endpoints. So we're going to
keep moving through this until we find it.
Alright, so I had to cut their terms of what
we're actually looking for is the word change,
not the word return. And I do a Ctrl F, it's
the first thing we find, of course, so this
is the key stats endpoint, which you can get
with the stats keyword in the URL. And if
you look down here, there's actually an awesome
group of momentum metrics. So you can do maximum
percent change five year percent change to
year percent change one year, year to date,
six months, three months, in case you can't
see us all zoom in a little bit. I guess you
can't zoom I There we go. Woof. That's a lot
of zoom. There we go. There we go. Alright,
so max change five year, two year, one year
here today, six months, three months, one
month, three days, sorry, 30 days and five
days. So this is the stats endpoint we're
going to do is we're going to copy this. And
we're just going to put it in our Jupyter
Notebook for now to come back to later. And
we also need the sandbox, base API endpoint.
zoom back to normal zoom, because it's a little
easier for me to navigate. So here's the testing
sandbox, we're going to find that this is
the base URL, we're going to put this in here,
right here. And then remember from last time,
we need to actually include stable here. So
this is a example of the base URL that we
need to hit with our API call. We're going
to call this string API underscore URL. And
then we actually need to specify a symbol.
So just like before, we're going to use Apple
as an example symbol. And we're going to use
an F string to interpolate that symbol variable
into this, we can take this right off the
end, because we're not actually trying to
parse a specific stat. And then we can use
the requests library to make an easy API call
to get this data. So to do that, we're going
to say data is equal to request dot get, and
then we're going to do API underscore URL.
And then we're going to sprint the status
code of that HTTP request to make sure that
went through properly. So this gets 400. We
did something wrong. What is it? sandbox that
is, oh, we didn't pass on our i x cloud API
token. So we need to do question mark token
equals IE x and then tab, it should autocomplete
and try that. Alright, so returns 200, which
means the API call is working properly. Let's
transform this into a JSON and put this again.
Alright, so as you can see this content. As
you can see, this contains all the information
that it should contain. The information that
we specifically want is the one year price
returns for every stock in the universe. So
to do that, it's actually quite easy. We're
going to cover that next. So to parse a JSON
object like this, we saw in the last section
that you just pass in square brackets, and
then the key of the dictionary. So the key
that we want now is one year change percent.
And all these keys generally don't start with
integers. They start with letters so that's
why it says year five instead of five year
and etc. But this is the We want, so we're
going to copy this, we're going to move down
here, we're going to add that in. And then
this should give us 1.42. So what does that
mean? That means that Apple has increased
in price 142% in the last year, which is pretty
impressive, it means that the stock has more
than doubled. But I guess that's what happens
when you sell a lot of expensive iPhones.
So just like before, we're going to kind of
loop through all of the stocks in our universe
and provide API calls for all of them. Instead
of living through them one by one, like we
saw in the last section, which is extremely
slow, we're going to move right on to executing
batch API calls, because that's kind of a
better practice. And there's no point practicing
executing single API calls when you'll generally
never do that in practice. So the first thing
we need to do is chunk our list of stocks
into groups of 100, using the chunks function
that we created last time. So to make this
easy, I've actually included a bunch of reusable
code from the last project here. So just run
this code cell that will give us the chunks
function. And then we use the chunks function
to divide our list of stocks into symbol groups
of length 100, then we create an empty list
called symbol strings. And then for every
100 stocks in this symbol groups list, we
create a comma separated list of strings and
then add them to this simple strings variable.
So if you go through every symbol string in
that list, we did this last project as well.
But we're gonna do it again, just for practice.
And then you print it, you'll see that this
is basically just five lists. And I'm sorry,
there should be four in Yeah, so this is just
five lists of length 100. So when I say lists,
they're not Python lists, they're actually
strings separated by commas, but there's five
of them. So here's one, here's another. Here's
where the third one and fourth one, the fifth
one, and I said there's five, there's actually
six sorry, that's because we have this short
one of length five at the end. Okay, so that's
all of this, I'm going to delete this out.
And we are going to move on to creating a
blank panda's data frame. So just like before,
we're going to call this final data frame.
And we're going to instantiate it by saying
PT, dot data, frame, and then columns equals,
and then you'll see up in this code, so I've
actually defined the names of the columns
we want here. So it's ticker price, when your
price return and number of shares to buy.
These are basically the same column names
as we used in the last project, except market
capitalization has been replaced by one year
price return here. So we can go down here
and specify those columns by saying columns
equals my underscore columns. And then, if
we print this, we should see an empty panda's
data frame with the columns we specify. Awesome,
so that's good. We're going to delete that.
And then we need to loop through all of our
symbol strings in the symbol string, symbol
strings object and create a batch API call.
So for symbol, string and symbol, strings,
and then we want to create a batch API call
URL, we're going to leave that as an empty
string for a moment. And then we want to create
a data variable. And that's going to be a
requests dot get method that accepts batch
API call URL, and then calls the JSON method
on it to transform it from a request subject
to a JSON object. So what goes in here? Let's
go back to the iCloud Doc's to look at fact
API call syntax again. Alright, so I just
did a Ctrl, F for batch here to find this
section, which tells you everything you need
to know about batch requests, so stock, and
then symbol, and then batch. Actually, we
want to query. So this syntax here is for
querying multiple endpoints for one stop,
but we want to query one endpoint for multiple
socks. So we actually want to use this syntax
here. So I'm going to copy this link address.
And I think this just gives us the last bit.
Now it gives us the entire thing, we're going
to change this to sandbox, because by default,
the docs give you a a live URL, not a sandbox
URL. And then we're gonna want to move down
here and change a few things here. So what
endpoint Do we need first, actually, to start,
move this up here so you can actually see
it. To start, let's take off this last parameter
and the range parameter. So those can both
be gone. And we're going to have to add back
our token equals, and then is cloud. Oh, sorry,
this isn't an F string. So that won't autocomplete
i x cloud. Yep, I x cloud API token, then
we're going to want to change the endpoints
next. So what goes there? Let's scroll back
up to see which endpoint we actually queried
earlier. Alright, so we use the stats endpoint.
So let's put that down into our batch API
call. stats. Then here, we want to change
our symbols to be an interpolated variable
that matches whatever the incrementer is of
our for loop. So that is symbol string. Alright,
so now what we need to do is, we're going
to run over this loop once, just to make sure
that we're getting a 200 HTTP code to make
sure that the HTTP request is being executed
properly. So to do that, we're going to print
data dot status code. And for this to actually
work properly, we're gonna have to remove
this JSON method temporarily from the HTTP
request. And then here, we're specifying what
we loop over, we're gonna want to change this
to a colon one, which tells us to loop only
over the first entry of that string. So if
this is working properly, we will get a response
of 200. Awesome, so that's good, we can get
rid of this status code attribute from the
data object and call this JSON method on it
to see what the structure of the HTTP response
actually looks like. So this is basically
a huge dictionary, it has many levels. So
at the top level, there is a key for this
ticker, and a value of a dictionary. And then
within that dictionary, there is a key for
the endpoint stats, and a dictionary for the
value. And then within that dictionary, there's
a key for every metric with a value that corresponds
to that metric. So we have to do multiple
levels of parsing here. But before we do that,
we actually have to loop over all of the stocks.
So let's let's build that loop. First off
we're going to do is we're going to say for
symbol in symbol, string, dot split, and we're
going to split on the colon character, which
separates all of the tickers in the symbol
string. So let's see what that split method
actually returns before we go any further,
Copy that, comment that out and then print
that oops, print that print, this is what
I want to print. There we go. Awesome. So
let's run that and see what it gives us. As
you can see, this is a Python list where each
item in the list is a symbol that corresponds
to all the comma separated symbols in the
symbol string. Okay, perfect. So we'll get
rid of this did not mean open my dev tools.
We will uncomment this. And then we will start
parsing the data in this loop. So we're going
to say. So what we want to do here is we want
to, for every ticker in this list, we want
to append the relevant metrics to the final
data frame. So to do that, we're going to
say final data frame is equal to final data
frame dot append. And then within this append
method, there's a few things we need, we need
a pandas series. And that pandas series will
accept a Python list. And it will also accept
the index equals my underscore columns argument
that, as you'll recall, from the first project,
this tells the append method were to actually
put the new metrics in the existing panda's
data frame. And then outside the panda series,
we're going to actually add ignore index equals
true. Okay, perfect. So this is where we want
to do our parsing. The first metric we want
is symbol. The second metric we want is price.
So to get price, we're going to need to do
data, and then parse the symbol, and then
parse the stats endpoint. And then we're going
to have to actually see what the name of the
price metric is within this. So let's write
here. Let's just print out one example of
this. Oh, sorry. All right there, right here.
Let's crank data. And then we'll use Apple
as an example ticker. And then we'll use stats.
And then let's just see what this gives us.
All right, there's giving us an error, because
we didn't actually format the rest of it properly.
But let's look and see here what we have for
price. I'm going to do Ctrl, F for price,
and see if anything highlights up here. market
cap employees. Doesn't look like this actually
has any price data. So we need to add here
to our endpoints, we're gonna say price, and
stats, let's go back gives us if we parse
price, I think this just gives us 504 hours.
Okay, perfect. So this is what we need to
do for price. We're going to replace Apple
with a symbol that we're looping over. And
then we're also going to pass in one year
price return. So we can use this print statement
up here to see what we need. We're getting
an error here because we're trying to open
To values to a data frame that has four values.
So for now, I'm just going to put in NA placeholders
for both of them. And actually, for the number
of shares to buy, that na placeholder is actually
going to stick. So we only need to figure
out the one year price return. So we'll run
this to get rid of that error. And then look
in here to see what we need to parse out for
the one year price return. All right. Year
One is what we need to search for, okay, here's
the metric year one change percent. So we'll
copy that, we will paste that there for now.
And then what we want to do is copy this,
paste it there, and then add this in as a
additional level of parsing to that. Alright,
let's run this, I'm going to take this off.
And this means that instead of looping over
just the first symbol string, we're going
to loop over all of the symbol strings. And
then inside of this big loop, I'm going to
print the final data frame so you can see
what it looks like. With any luck, this should
be okay. I'm sorry, I'm going to do this again
and remove this print statement. Alright.
Float object is not sub scriptable. Huh, that's
because we need to change this endpoint to
stats price. Alright, so this will take a
sec to run. It's a pretty big data frame to
build. Awesome, everything looks good. So
just to recap, what we did here was, we created
an empty panda's data frame with the columns
that are specified here. And then we looped
over all of the symbol strings in our symbol
strings object, we created a batch API call
URL for those symbol strings that hits two
different endpoints, it hits the price endpoint
and it hits the stats endpoint. And then we
use the requests library to execute an HTTP
request and get that data in the form of a
JSON object. For every string in that comma
separated string of string, or sorry, for
every symbol in that comma separated string
of symbols. We split them using the split
method to get a list of them. And then we
looped over that list to a pend the data for
each symbol to our empty panda's data frame.
And then we printed the panda's data frame.
And it looks like this. Everything seems to
be working so far, so we can move on to removing
low momentum stocks from our panda's data
frame. Alright, so like the other code cells
in this project, this has a bit of background
information, it says the investment strategy
that we're building seeks to identify the
50 highest momentum stocks in the s&p 500.
Because of this, the next thing we need to
do is remove all the stocks in our data frame
that fall below this momentum threshold. To
do that, we'll sort the panda's data frame
by one year price return and then drop all
stocks outside the top 50. That sounds easy
enough, and pandas actually makes it very
easy to sort data within the data frame. So
we're going to use some built in functionality
of the pandas library to do this. Alright,
so the first thing we're gonna do is call
final data frame. And then on this final data
frame, we're going to call the pandas method
that allows us to sort the data frame based
on values contained as columns. And that method
is sorted values. Now, this takes a few different
parameters. The first one is the column that
you want to use to sort so we're going to
use one year price return, if you just type
in one and then tab, it might autocomplete.
Now if it doesn't autocomplete, you can just
go up here and copy it, copying is always
a good idea, because there's lots of different
ways you could spell this and just kind of
avoid any typos, although typos are pretty
easy bug to fix. Alright, so one year price
return. And then the next parameter it accepts
is whether or not you want it to sort ascending
or sort by descending. Now, we want to sort
descending values so that the highest momentum
stocks are at the top. So to do that, we'll
say ascending equals false. And then the last
thing we want to say is in place equals true.
Now, if you've worked with pandas lots in
the past, you're definitely familiar with
this in place equals true method. What this
does is it changes the function from just
returning a sorted data frame to actually
modifying the original data frame. Now, to
see this in action, you can take it away,
run this, and it shows the highest one year
price return stocks at the top. But then,
if you run that line, and then print the original
data frame right below it, it will not return
the sort of data frame, it will just return
the original one. So this shows you that without
the in place equals true method that doesn't
actually modify the original date. Right now,
if you add the in place equals true method,
that's not true, it will return the sorted
data frame. So that's how we start the values.
Now what we need to do is modify the panda's
data frame so that it only includes the first
50 rows. Now to do that, it's actually quite
easy. You can just pass in the dash 50 Yeah,
dash 50 or sorry, not dash colon 50 specification
into square brackets like this. Now, the indices
are all different now because it's been sorted.
So I'm actually going to just make sure that
this is right by doing length. Yeah, so it's
50. Great. So this has 50 stocks now. And
then to make this so that it actually modifies
the original pandas data frame, all you need
to do is say file dot train equals finals
that frame equals 50. Now if you print it,
it will just return a data frame with 50 rows.
Awesome. So awesome. So one last thing that
we can do is to reset the index. So it doesn't
start and have kind of this random list of
numbers. So the easiest way to do that is
just with pandas reset underscore index method
doesn't actually accept any parameters. But
as you can see, it does the job. Now, just
like before. Without the in place equals true
method, this doesn't actually modify the original
data frame, so we'll have to specify that
in here. You'll notice as you work more and
more with the pandas library that this in
place equals true parameter works in almost
all of the functions that you use regularly
in the library. So there we go. So just to
recap what we did here, we took our final
data frame object, which contains price and
momentum data on all the stocks in the s&p
500. And we sorted its rows based on their
one year price returns such that the highest
momentum stocks are at the top, and then we
use the in place equals true parameter to
actually modify the original data frame instead
of just returning a temporary copy. Once that
was done in the next line, we modified the
data frames such that it only contains the
50 stocks with the highest price momentum.
And then we use pandas reset underscore index
method to change the index of the data frame
so that it actually runs from zero to 49,
or zero to 50, I should say, zero to 49. Yeah,
zero 49. And then we just printed out the
final data frame on the last line. So with
that out of the way, we can move on to actually
calculating the number of shares to buy for
this simple momentum strategy. Alright, so
just like in the last project, this is going
to be kind of similar, the only change we're
going to make is that we're going to wrap
the functionality of accepting the port portfolio
size inside of a function because we'll actually
be using the same functionality later in this
tutorial, when we build a better and more
robust strategy, you can actually see that
heading here, we started in the next code
sale. So to do that, we're gonna have to wrap
it in a function and it's probably not necessary,
wrap it in a function, you could just copy
paste code, it is a Jupyter Notebook after
all, but it is definitely better to create
functions if you're ever going to reuse any
code. And since we're not building too many
functions in this Python course, it's kind
of a good excuse to practice building Python
functions. So if you're familiar with Python
functions, and since we've already done this
same functionality in the last project, try
to pause this video here and try to complete
the function yourself without watching me
code through it. So break now and try that
yourself. Alright, so we're going to do is
we're going to say def portfolio underscore
size. So if you're not familiar with function
syntax, in Python, this is just defining a
new function called portfolio size. And the
empty brackets here means that it's accepts
no parameters. And then the first thing we're
gonna do is we need to create a global variable
in here. So this function can define a variable,
and then it can be accessed outside of that
function. So if you were to do that as global,
and we're going to call this variable at portfolio
underscore size, and then what we're gonna
do is we're gonna say portfolio. portfolio,
underscore size equal to input. And then just
like before, we're gonna say, enter this size
of your portfolio. Now, as we saw in the last
project, we need to make some special functionality
here such that if someone tries to enter a
string into this Python input, it will tell
them to re enter a float value. So we're going
to do inverse A try float, portfolio, underscore
size. And if this returns an error, we're
going to say, print. That is not a number.
And then we're going to print again and say,
Please try it again. And then we are going
to say, basically, this exact same functionality.
Great. And then the only other change we need
to make is to actually specialize this accept
statement so that it only works on the certain
type of error that would happen if someone
entered a string into this. So that type of
error is a value error. So we'll do that here.
And actually not to look at this, this is
a bit unnecessary with two separate print
statements. So I'm going to copy this here
and do in newline character and try that.
Okay, so let's run this and see if it defines
properly. Awesome, it does. So we're going
to use this portfolio size function to accept
a portfolio size now and then we're going
to use it again later to accept a portfolio
size for our better and more realistic momentum
strategy. But we're going to make sure this
works. And actually, before we proceed, one
thing that's worth noting is that this should
function should be called portfolio input.
And it doesn't actually have to be called
portfolio input. But it definitely should
not be called portfolio size, because then
it has the same name as this variable. And
that's kind of an easy way to introduce logical
bugs in your code is by having a function
and a variable with this same name. So we're
going to change this to portfolio input, and
we're going to run this code cell to define
it, then we're going to test it by running
portfolio underscore input. And then we are
going to print portfolio underscore size.
Now, here, it's especially important to print
the variable that's defined inside the function
because we need to make sure that this, this
global keyword is working properly. So let's
run this and see what happens. So another
size of your portfolio will enter $1,000,
and it should print $1,000. Awesome. Now let's
try this again, we'll put in a string. So
I will say, my portfolio is too small to matter
to you. That's kind of sad, but we're gonna
try it and then it says that is not a number,
please try again. Okay, so my portfolio is
one. Awesome, so our portfolio input function
is working properly, we can now move on to
looping through our panda's data frame and
calculating the number of shares to buy. So
the first thing we need to do is actually
calculate our position size. And to do that,
I'm going to actually enter a slightly larger
portfolio. So we're gonna say, That's 1000.
That's a million. Let's do 10 million. And
what we need to do is calculate position size.
So to calculate, to calculate position size,
we're going to do position size is equal to
float portfolio size, divided by the length
of our panda's data frame. So we'll say length
of final data frame, and then you can pick
the length of any column, I usually do dot
index for this. So this gives us let's print
it out to see what the position size is. This
gives us is that 200,000? Yep, yep, 200,000.
And that makes sense, because we're just doing
10 million divided by 50. So that kind of
math checks out. And then the next thing to
do is we need to loop through all of the rows
in the panel data frame. So for that, we're
gonna say for i in range, zero, and then the
length of the data frame, final data frame.
And then let's just print it to see what happens.
So this goes from zero to 49. And if we go
back up to a panda's data frame, we can see
that the last index is 49. And the first index
is zero. So that's awesome. That looks like
it should work properly. Let's take away this
print statement now. And we're going to loop
through all of the entries within the number
of shares to buy column. Now, the way to do
that is with pandas LLC functionality, we're
gonna pass in I for the row, and we're going
to pass in number of shares to buy for the
column. Now, what we want to do here is just
make sure that we're accessing this properly.
So we're going to say zero. And then at the
bottom, we're going to say final underscore
data. Now, if this works properly, what should
happen is every entry in the column of number
of shares to buy should be replaced with a
zero. So let's try this. Awesome. Now we're
getting a warning here, because it's saying,
I think this is actually a bug with penisula,
I'm not sure the setting with copy warning,
it's because it says, If value is trying to
be set on a copy of a slice from a DataFrame,
try using dot LLC equals value instead. And
that's kind of exactly what we're doing. So
I'm not really sure what's going on here.
But you can definitely ignore that for now.
So now what we need to do is calculate actually
how many shares to buy. So to do that, we're
going to have to access to the Price column
of the data frame, and we're gonna have to
divide the position side by price. So first,
we'll take position size, and then we will
divide it by this LLC method, but instead
of number of shares to buy, we're just going
to replace it with price. Now, let's run this
and see what happens. Awesome. So as you can
see, this is giving us fractional shares for
everything. And like we talked about in the
last section of this course, we don't want
fractional shares for this. So the last thing
we need to do is wrap all of this in a math
dot floor function. Oops. And this will round
every number in this number shares to by column
to the lowest, closest interviewer. So let's
try that. Awesome. It's looking good. I think
we are ready to proceed to building our better
and more realistic momentum strategy. So let's
do that now. Alright, so it's time for us
to build a better and more realistic quantitative
momentum strategy. Now, what does it mean
for a momentum strategy to be better? There's
a lot of different ways you could define it.
Obviously, a strategy is better if it performs
better, but it's kind of hard to tell that
in without foresight. So what I mean by building
a better momentum strategy is that real world
quantitative investment firms typically differentiate
between high quality momentum stocks and low
quality momentum stocks. So a high quality
momentum stock is a stock that over a long
period of time shows slow and steady price
returns. So you know, if a stock returns half
a percent every month for a year, that would
be kind of like a high quality, slow and steady
momentum stock, a low quality momentum stock
might not show any momentum for a long period
of time and then surge upwards over a short
period of time. So if you haven't done VAT
returns 0% for 11 months and then 10% in one
month, that would be considered a low quality
momentum stock, even though it's one year
price return would be 10%. And might be better
than a lot of other stocks. So it might be
hard to tell why that definition of high quality
versus low quality stocks is important. But
the reason why is because you want stocks
that are seeing price returns in reaction
to slow and steady business progress, not
one time Business News. So the example that
I used here, as I said, the reason why high
quality momentum stocks are preferred is because
low quality momentum can often be caused by
short term news that is unlikely to be repeated
in the future, like an FDA drug approval for
a biotechnology company. So this kind of begs
the question, how do you identify high quality
momentum stocks, and the best way to do it
is to take a basket of different time series
momentum metrics, and use them all when calculating
which momentum stocks to include in your strategy.
So to identify high quality momentum, we're
going to build a quantitative momentum strategy
that select stocks that have the highest percentiles
of one month price return, three month price
returns, six months price returns, and one
year price returns. And we're going to call
this our high quality momentum strategy. So
you'll see that I use the abbreviation of
HQ m fairly often. And that stands for high
quality momentum. Let's start by building
our data frame so so the first thing we need
to do is actually specify our columns. This
is going to be a much longer Python list than
what we used in the past for columns, because
it's going to include so many more metrics.
So the first thing we're going to use is ticker,
and then price. And then number of shares
to buy. We're gonna have to create a bunch
of slots for our, for our return metrics and
our percentile metrics. So to give you like
a broad overview, we're gonna fill in one
column for each time period that has how much
that stock has returned in the last year.
And then right beside that column, there's
going to be another column that has the percentile
score of that return relative to all of the
other stocks in the universe. So we're going
to do one year, Christ's return, one year,
return percentile, and then six month, price
return. And then six month return percentile,
and then helps three, what's the next one,
three months, yeah, three month price return.
And then three month, return for same trial,
and then one month price return. And one month,
return percentile. Alright, let's run this
just to make sure it's formatted properly.
Awesome. So now we can create our data frame
which is going to be HQ n data frame is equal
to PD data frame. And we're going to specify
columns equals HQ m underscore columns. Awesome.
Now let's print this HTML data frame to make
sure that it is an empty panda's data frame
with the columns that we specified. Awesome.
Now, we can start looping over our symbol
string object that we created earlier for
symbol, string, and symbol strings. And here's
where we have to create our batch API calls
and do kind of all the similar logic that
we use before. So the first thing we're going
to do is execute our batch API call. So we
can actually use very similar logic to that
as before. So we're going to scroll up here,
find our old batch API call, and use the same
logic because we don't actually need any metrics
that weren't included in this. So we'll copy
both of these lines. So what we're grabbing
here is the batch API call URL, and the HTTP
request that grabs the JSON object from that
URL and stores it in our Python script. So
we'll scroll back down to where we were here.
And we're going to add this to this loop.
All right, and now we need to loop through
all of the symbols in that symbol string.
So we're gonna use for symbol and symbol underscore
string dot split on the comma, character,
just like before. And then in here, we need
to parse out all of these metrics. So whenever
I'm doing high level parsing like this, I
find that it's easiest to just literally copy
this in, and then you can replace each metric
with what you need. So this is going to be
an append method. First HQ m underscore data
frame is equal to h qm underscore data frame
dot append. And then in here, we have to pass
in all the things that we've been using throughout
this course. So first, it'll be a panda's
series. And inside that pandas series, there'll
be a pipe tongueless we'll fill that in later.
And then we have to say index equals HTML
underscore columns. And then here we have
to add the special ignore, index equals true.
Alright, let's move back inside this Python
list, we're going to paste those metrics.
And then I'm just going to get the indentation
looking a little better here. So do that.
Alright, so one easy thing we can do is all
of the percentile metrics, we're just going
to fill in to start with na. And we will loop
back through all of those metrics. And use
the Sai pi library to calculate their percentile
scores later. Alright, so that's easy. ticker
will be replaced by symbol, which is the incrementer
of the for loop that we're in here, price
will be replaced by the price metric, the
price endpoint from the cloud API. So to do
that, we're going to say, data and then symbol.
And then price. Awesome, the number of shares
to buy just like before will be filled in
with an NA placeholder. And the one year price
return we actually already parsed out in our
last example, so we can just go back up and
copy that down to our new high quality momentum
strategy. Alright, so here's the original
parsing of the one year price return, we can
copy that, scroll back down to where we were.
Sorry, right here. All right. And we will
replace this with the parsing of the equivalent
metric. Awesome. And then, as you can see,
here, we are just going to copy this down
to all of the other price returns and then
change them to fit. So this is month six instead
of year one. And then we'll copy this and
move it down to here. And this will be month
three instead of MONTH six. And this will
be month one instead of MONTH three. All right,
so let's run this to see if it works. And
then I'll do a quick recap of everything we
did in that cell. So there is invalid syntax
here. There's a missing comment there. Let's
try this again. Length of past values is 11.
Index implies 10. What's going on 1-234-567-8910
11. So we're missing a comma here. And if
we run this, now, it should work. Alright,
so that is running correctly, it looks like
we're gonna run this again and print out the
final date, or sorry, it's not the final data
frame anymore. It's the HTM data frame. And
see what happens. All right, so this is a
big data frame quite a bit bigger than the
ones we worked with. In the past. It has ticker
price number of shares to buy when your price
return, one year return percentile, six month
price, return six month return percentile,
three month price, return three month term,
percentile, one month, press return and one
month return percentile. So we have lots left
to do to this data frame. But first, we're
going to go through to each of these percentile
columns. And we're going to replace these
na values with a percentile score that shows
how high a company's momentum is for that
time period, relative to all the other stocks
in the universe. So this is we're gonna do
this, there's going to be a lot of repeated
logic in this section. So I find the easiest
way to do this is to create a array called
time periods. And then inside this array,
we're going to create a string for each time
period that we're going to be looping over.
And then we can use string interpolation to
make this much easier. So we're basically
going to say our time periods are one year,
and six months, and three months, and one
month. Now, he's not exactly clear yet how
we're going to be using this, what we're going
to do is we're going to loop through all of
our columns and replace this value with a
value from this list so that we have to write
the logic one, the logic ones, but we can
actually use a loop to calculate the percentile
scores for all of the percentile columns.
So that's kind of what we're doing here. Now,
the next thing to do is create the actual
loop. So for row in HQ, m dot data frame dot
index, and then we need to use another loop
inside of this. This inner loop is going to
loop over the time periods object that we
just created. So for time period in time periods,
And then here, we're going to use the pandas
LLC method to change the value of each time
period column. So we're gonna say, HQ m, data
frame dot LLC, the row is going to be this
row incrementer, that we're looping over here.
And then the column is going to be we're gonna
make an F string here. And we're going to
say, it's going to look something like this
with an interpolated value. And so let's copy
that, we will put that in here. And then this
is the time period that we want to interpolate.
So we will Oh, and just so you know, you've
probably seen me do this quite a few times
in this course, all that I'm doing there is
I highlight the string, and then I do a, you
know, I enter the curly bracket character,
so I just enter that character, and it will
automatically wrap whatever you have highlighted
in those curly brackets, it's quite a nice
little feature. Okay, so we're going to replace
this with time period. And then what we want
to do is assign that to something. So to start,
let's just try assigning them all to zero.
And then oops, didn't mean to edit that. And
then at the end of this code cell, we will
print HTM underscore data frame. Let's see
what happens. Alright, so you can see all
the percentile scores are being replaced with
zero, which is awesome. But that's not quite
exactly what we need to do yet, we need to
actually use the sci fi stats module to calculate
the percentile score based on whatever's inside
of this. So let's do that. Now. The function
we're gonna use is stats dot percentile of
score. And then how this function works is
it takes two arguments, the first argument
is the entire column. And then the second
argument is an entry from that column. So
to start, we're going to need the column which
is simply HQ m, issue m underscore data frame,
I'm going to scroll this up to make sure you
can see it, and then we need to pass in this
string. Sorry, not that string, we need to
pass in the this string as the column name
and then interpolate in the time period. So
it will look like this. Awesome. Now, what
we need to do next is interpolate in the time
period value, so we need to change this to
an F string, and then change this to time
period. Alright, the last thing we need to
do is put a comma here, and add in the actual
value that we want to calculate. So what we're
going to do is use the LFC method, I'm going
to copy this and put it in as a placeholder.
And then all I have to do is change the oops,
the column name to match this. Now, I know
that this is a really long Python line, we're
gonna refactor it in a second. So just hang
tight. Copy that, and put that in here. All
right, looks like I got some duplicate apps
in parentheses. Okay, let's try this. Alright,
so these look quite good. You can see that
Apple, which has one of the highest percentile
scores for one year has a sorry, has one of
the highest momentum scores for one year has
a 99th percentile. So that's good. Everything
here looks pretty logical to me. So what we're
going to do now is refactor this code, so
it's much more readable. So first thing we're
going to do is we're gonna say, change row
equals in our sorry, change column equals
something and percentile call is equal to
something, the percentile column is this.
So we can copy that and replace this with
this. And the return column is this. Or the
change column mean? Sorry. Alright, so let's
go back through and replace these. Oops. And
we'll go down here and replace this with the
same thing. Okay, this is quite a bit more
readable. Let's scroll up. So you can see
what actually did here. So basically, this
is saying, we're going to take the HTM data
frame, and at row of row, and in the percentile
column, we're going to assign it to this calculation
stats dot percentile of score. And then we're
going to call this H chrome underscore data
frame a change call. So this is the column
that we're using to base our percentile calculations
on. And this is the entry from that column
whose percentile score we want to calculate.
Now, one other thing that we could do to this
is we could say, change this import somehow.
So if we go back to the top, and we say, copy
this, and move up to here, and from Sai pi,
import stats, and then we could say, okay,
percentile of score is what we want. Score.
Score. Okay, so what this is, we run this
import now. So we're saying from the side
PI's stats module, import the percentile of
score, function as score, so we can go down
and erase that very long function call and
just type score instead. And all those changes
will make this much more readable, it means
you won't have to scroll horizontally to actually
see the entire line. Just so you know, in
Python, and most software development kind
of considered a bad practice to have really
long lines. So if you can break it up like
this, it's much more readable and much better,
I think, I believe too much. Take this. Alright,
but almost fits on one line. Now, it's still
quite a long call. But if we run this, now,
it should have all the same functionality.
Great. So now we can move on to actually calculating
the HTM score. Now, we haven't actually talked
about the H COVID score yet. So let's do that.
Now. The HTM score is just going to be an
arithmetic mean of all the percentile scores
for the momentum returns that we calculated
in the last section. So to do that, we're
going to import the mean function from pythons
built in statistics module. So we're gonna
say from statistics, import mean, let's run
that to see if it works properly. Now, the
way the mean function works is you can just
say, like, a few numbers in here, what's the
mean of two and six? Well, this should be
four. And mean takes one position. Sorry,
this has to be a list in here. Yeah, so that's
kind of the mean function works, it's kind
of exactly what you'd expect, we're going
to use that to calculate the average of all
of the percentile scores that we calculated
in the last section of this project. And we
actually have to do this row by row. So the
first thing to do is to create a loop. We've
been using lots of loops in here, but it's
good practice. So for throw in HTN, data frame
dot index, and then the first thing we're
going to do is create a empty Python list
called momentum percentiles. And then we're
going to loop through all of the appropriate
columns in the data frame to get the momentum
score for that row. So let's first do momentum,
percentiles equals empty Python list. And
then we need to loop through all of the time
periods and the time period object that we
created earlier. So for time, period and time
periods, and then we need to append the momentum
scores to this momentum percentiles list.
So momentum percentiles dot append. And then
in here, we want to say, an LLC method on
the HTM data frame HTML underscore data frame,
dot LLC, the first entry will be the row,
the second entry will be an F string. And
inside that F string, we are going to say,
time period, and then return percentile. Alright,
let's try this just once. And see if we actually
get a reasonable momentum percentiles object.
Alright, so we get 8585 6235. Let's go up
here and see if that looks right. 8585 62
and 35. Awesome. So now what we can do is
calculate the mean. And we're going to put
that mean in the HTM score column. Now, looking
at this, in hindsight, we don't actually have
an H COVID score column doing. What we're
going to do now is go back up to the top and
add our h qm score to our columns. So first,
add this to this column. For now, it's going
to be an NA placeholder, just like all of
these were h score. So we have to add and
add a placeholder here. And now we just need
to go back to here and rerun all of our code
cells. If this runs correctly, then we know
that everything we just did worked awesome.
So now, we need to say that each gram column
needs to be assigned the mean of all of the
values in the momentum percentiles list. So
we can do that again, using an LLC method.
We'll say HTM data frame, dot LLC, and then
the first sector This is row The second is
HTM store. And this needs to be assigned to
the mean of momentum. percentiles and now
if we print the HM data frame after running
this All of the entries in our HTML data frame
should have a HTM score calculated on the
very right. Now the only other change we need
to make is to delete this limiter on the end
of index. And let's see how this looks. Awesome.
So it looks like we've successfully calculated
an HTM score for every stock in our panda's
data frame. Let's do a quick recap of what
we did here. So from the Python statistics
module, we imported the mean function. And
then we loop over all of the rows in our panda's
data frame. For each row, we re instantiated
an empty Python list called momentum percentiles.
And then, for every time period in our time
periods list, we lived through the time periods
and to the momentum percentiles list, we upended
the percentile scores for that stock, and
then we used the LSC method to assign the
average of all of those percentile scores
to the HTM score column. Then, to conclude,
we printed out that panda's data frame. Alright,
let's move on to selecting the 50 best momentum
stocks. So as before, we can identify the
50 best momentum stocks in our universe by
sorting the panda's data frame on the score
that matters to us. So in the last section,
that was one year price return, and this section
is actually going to be HTM score. So the
logic here is very similar, we're going to
do HTM underscore data frame. And we're going
to use the sort values method, sorry, underscore
values. And we're going to pass in here is
the HTM score. And then we also need ascending
equals false. So this will put our highest
ranked momentum stocks at the top. And the
last thing we need is in place equals true,
this will cause the store value function to
actually modify the original data frame. So
let's print it out and see what this looks
like. Alright, we can see our top few stocks
all have extremely high momentum here, which
is a great sign. Okay. The next thing we need
to do is to drop all stocks except for the
top 50. And we saw how to do this earlier,
you just say HTM data frame equals HTM data
frames, and then index it from calling 50.
And if we print this out, now, you can see
that it is shorter than it was before, it's
hard to tell how much because we haven't reset
the index yet. So let's do reset underscore
index. Sorry, that's a method, not an attribute.
And it goes from zero to 49. Awesome. The
last thing we need to do is Pat place in place
equals true into this. And then if we print
it out, we should see our finalized hmda data
frame that goes from zero to 49 on the index
column. Awesome. Great. So we are ready to
start calculating the number of shares to
buy. And we'll use the portfolio input function
that we created earlier. So let's run that.
And named portfolio input is not defined as
we as I spelt it wrong. Let's do $1 million
portfolio. And then in the next section, we
need to calculate the number of shares to
buy and this is exactly what we did before.
So first, we need to calculate position size,
which is going to be the size of our portfolio
divided by how many stocks are in it. So the
first thing we need to do is take the float
value of portfolio underscore size, and then
divide it by the length of our HTM data frame.
And you can take any column here, I usually
take the index, just like that, and then let's
print out position size 20,000, that looks
right. Awesome. Now we need to loop through
a row or panda's data frame. So we'll say
for I and H m data frame index. And then we
need to assign the number of shares to buy
to the number of shares and I call them so
we'll use the LLC method to do that issue
dot frame dot LLC. And then we'll pass in
i comma and then the number of shares to buy.
To test this out, let's assign them all a
value of zero first, and then print it out
to see what happens. That comma shouldn't
be there. Awesome number of shares to buy
has all been assigned zero. Great. So like
before, what we're going to do now is we're
going to divide our position size by the company's
stock price. And the easiest way to do that
is to copy this over and replace the number
of shares to buy column with the Price column.
Price. Okay, this looks good. We're getting
decimals again. So the last thing to do is
wrap this in the math dot floor function.
And just like that, we successfully calculated
the number of shares to buy for each stock
In our HCM data frame, oh, there's a there's
one thing actually that we did wrong earlier.
So you'll notice now that there's a, there's
a new column called index. And the reason
why that's there is because when we did our
reset index earlier, I can't believe I didn't
notice that at the time. But there's an optional
parameter here. And just to give you ever
been more information about how to use Jupyter
notebooks, if you want to know what possible
parameters are available for a function or
a method, you can do Shift Tab and this will
pop up. And what we want to do is say drop
equals true. What this does is drop equals
true. What this does is, the old index just
gets removed from the pandas DataFrame completely.
That's not the case, I'm going to show you
exactly how you debug this. I'm going to do
pandas dot, and then reset index to go to
the actual documentation. Oh, sorry, I'll
tell you exactly what the bug is here. And
the reason why this happened is because we
ran this more than once. So if we just go
back up here, to where we initialize the issue
data frame, and then run all the way down,
this problem will be solved. See, just like
that, it's gone. It goes index and then ticker.
Okay, so just to recap, we should have originally
put this here, drop equals true in our reset
index method we didn't and that caused that
to be an extra index column, which we've now
fixed. So now when we run this, we get the
number of shares to buy, and all the other
columns we need. Alright, so the next thing
we need to do is format our panda's data frame
into a Microsoft Excel document for use by
non technical LSI users. So the first thing
we need to do to do this, we're gonna actually
to back up a bit. To do this, we're gonna
be using the same libraries we did in the
last project, which is XLS x writer. And to
start, the first thing we need to do is initialize
a writer object. So to do that you do writer
equals pd.xl, XL, writer. And then the first
thing you need to pass in is the name of the
Excel file that you want to create. In this
case, we're going to call it momentum underscore
strategy dot XLS x. The next thing you want
to add is the engine, which is engine equals
XLS. x writer. Alright, so the next thing
we need to do is say, Hmm, data frame, got
to underscore Excel. And the first argument
of this function is going to be the writer
object we just created. The second argument
is going to be the sheet name. In this case,
it's going to be sheet underscore name equals
moment momentum strategy. And the last argument
is going to be index equals false. Alright,
so run that code cell, and we can proceed.
Now, the next thing we need to do is actually
create the formats that we need, we actually
created all of these formats in the last section
of this course. So or in the last project
of this course, I should say, so I'm not going
to make you work through this again, instead,
we're just going to run this code cell to
proceed. Now we need to actually loop through
the columns format dictionary, again, to apply
the formats that we created to the columns
that we have. So the easiest way to do this,
in my opinion, is to scroll all the way back
here to where we initially created our columns,
which is right here. And then I'm going to
copy all of these and use this as kind of
a basis for our dictionary that we're going
to build. Alright, so we're going to paste
that there. Now we need to start with column
name. So it's just gonna we're just gonna
be doing this to start a, b, c, d, e. Now
note that if I was in like an actual development
environment, I typically write big programs
in VS code. I can do this much faster with
multi cursor. Ah, Jupyter notebooks are better
for visualizations and other sorts of things,
though. Alright, so our columns are going
to be from a through L. And then we're going
to want to wrap each of these inside of a
list. Now depending on your operating system,
there's different ways that you can enable
this multi cursor functionality that I'm using
right now, I am using Linux, and I'm just
Ctrl clicking so that I can add the start
of the list each line. And then Oops, I'm
going to move back to the start of the list,
I should try this again. Now what I'm going
to do is try to move to the end of the line
and add the closing list brackets not gonna
be super pretty because some of these have
columns and don't look back before the comma,
try that. Okay, what do we have any of these
broken? Last one is? Great. Okay, so now we
have a columns from a dictionary where the
keys are each column letter, and the values
are a list with one item where that one item
is the name of that column. The last thing
we need to do is work through these one by
one and apply the template we want. So this
will be string underscore template, price
will be dollar underscore template, number
of shares to buy will be string, note energy
template, not string template. One year price
return will be percent, one year return percentile,
so most of these are going to be percent template
moving down. So I'm just going to copy this
and paste it. Alright, this is looking good.
So far, let's run this code. So next to make
sure that this dictionary is actually formatted
properly, so it ran correctly, which is good.
Alright, so the next thing we need to do is
loop through every key in this dictionary
and apply the right format to that column.
So let's try that. So we're gonna say, for
column in column, underscore formats, dot
keys. And let's just print column to make
sure this is working, right, A, B, C, D, E,
F, G, H, i, j, k, l, that looks good. Alright,
the next thing we need to do is use the method
for XLS writer that actually applies a format
to a specific column. As we saw in the last
project, the way to do that is we need to
call the writer object and then from that
writer object, we need to access the sheets
attribute, which is a list of all the sheets
in the Excel file. And then we need to access
the momentum strategy tab from that list.
And then we need to call the set column method
on that, I was going to take three parameters,
let's put two commas in here to reflect that.
The first parameter is the format that we
want to apply. So the first parameter is the
column that we want to apply the format to.
So it will look something like this A through
A, the second parameter is the column width,
which we're going to say 18 pixels. Actually,
let's do something like 22. And then the last
is which column we're going to want to apply
to that. So we'll say string underscore format.
And then let's just test that this morning,
I will say, writer dot save. And then if we
run this, what happens, right, it's actually
similar to strategy string format is not Oh,
it's because string template. All right, now
let's go to our folder and see if this is
working right. starter files momentum strategy,
so is there which is good. If we open this
up, we can see that the data in here, we can
see that the first column has been formatted
properly, we're going to go format the headers
in the same way that we did in the last section,
so don't worry about that yet. Alright, so
now we need to change this set column method
such that it actually is dynamically applying
formats to each column in the data frame.
So first thing to do is change the column
like this. And the second thing to do is to
add a two. Here, we're going to access the
column format dictionary, we're gonna pass
in the column key. Alright, let's try that
what happens now columns is not defined. That's
because that should be column. Now if we go
to our Excel file, still not working. And
that is we saw this in the last project, too.
We need to go back up and re initialize our
writer object and go down to the bottom again.
Right, what is happening here, we have some
kind of bug on writer dot save. Why is that?
I'll save Oh, I see. Okay, so here in the
writer dot sheets, dot set column method.
This is actually a list and we need to actually
parse it to get the format that we want. That
format is in the second item of the list,
which is at index one. So we press one there,
and this should work properly and we can go
see our oops, ignore that. We can go see our
newly formatted Excel file. Alright, so the
format's are being applied to each column
properly, you can see that they're not actually
wide enough because the column names in this
project are longer than the column names in
the last project. So let's change that 22
to 25. And then the last thing we need to
do is actually check format the column headers.
And we saw in the last section that the easiest
way to do that is just overriding them using
the right methods. So the right method is
similar to the set color method, except instead
of taking in an entire column for the first
one, it takes just a cell from a column. So
we're going to do here is we're going to access
the column. And then once that's the first
cell of that column, here, we're going to
specify the column width. And then here, we
are going to do the exact same thing and apply
the format from the second entry of that list.
Alright, let's go back to the top of our formatting
the Excel format section, run through all
of this again, and with any luck, this should
be formatted exactly like we want. There we
go. Alright, so you can see that this is not
good, because what is going on in this top
row? Well, I see, this doesn't actually take
column with this takes the value that we want
to put in it. And that's just a mistake on
my part, a logical mistake. That should be
this list at index zero. So let's copy that
list, put it here and put index zero. We'll
move this writer dot save method, back down
to the last column, this Jupyter Notebook
or the last cell of distributor notebook,
rather than we'll move back up to where the
writer object was initialized and run it to
the bottom. Now, when we open up our momentum
strategy Excel file, we should see that the
entire notebook is done, we have ticker price
number of shares to buy one year price return,
one year return percentile, six month price,
return six months return percentile, three
month price, return three months return percentile,
one month, price, return, one month, return
percentile, and HTM score. Now, you can see
that all of these aren't actually formatted
like they should be. So all these percentile
scores are multiplied by, I guess 100 over
what their actual value should be. So let's
go back into a notebook and fix that. If we
scroll up here. We're gonna go all the way
back to where our percentile scores were originally
calculated. And that is right here, I think.
Yeah. So note, sorry, this is the HTML score,
we need to go up a little bit further. Right,
so this is where they originally calculated,
we're going to move to the end of this calculation,
and divide it by 100. And then, we're going
to go back to where we created our h qm DataFrame.
And run this entire notebook to the very end.
All right, so this should all run with no
problems. We're waiting on our input here,
so I'll do a million dollars again. And this
should run to the bottom with no problem.
Alright, let's check out our new Excel file
to see if those percentile scores were reduced
in magnitude like they should have been. Alright,
so we have one year price return and then
9.2. That looks good. Alright, so you can
see that this has been sorted by hmm score
properly, we go from 99.1, down to 81.9. And
just like that, we have a list of the 50 highest
momentum stocks in the s&p 500, along with
the number of shares that you should buy if
you want to create an equal weight basket
on those 50 stocks. So that concludes our
second project for this algorithmic trading
and Python course, I hope you enjoyed this
project. In the next section, we're going
to learn how to build a value investing strategy
that buys the 50 cheapest stocks in the s&p
500 based on a composite score of a number
of different value investing metrics. So I
will see you there in the next project, which
is going to be a value investing strategy.
Now, for anyone who's not familiar with value
investing, it just means trying to buy stocks
and other investments that are cheap relative
to our SL. For anyone who's not familiar with
value investing, it just means trying to buy
stocks and other investments that are cheap
relative to our assessment of their intrinsic
value. There's many different ways to try
to estimate the intrinsic value of a stock
or other investments. So what we're going
to do in this project is we're going to build
a simple value strategy that relies on one
metric. And then we're going to improve that
value strategy by creating a composite value
strategy that takes into account many different
metrics when trying to estimate intrinsic
value. So to start, let's navigate into I'm
in my terminal here in my home directory.
Let's navigate into our algorithmic trading
Python folder. And then let's launch our Jupyter
Notebook. Sorry, before we do that, we have
to launch our virtual environment. And then
we can launch our Jupyter Notebook with Python
dash m notebook. A Jupyter Notebook will open
up in your browser Then you're gonna want
to navigate into our starter Files folder
and open up the quantitative value strategy
ipnb notebook. Alright, so, like I said before
the value investing means investing in the
stocks that are cheapest relative to common
measures of business value like earnings or
assets. For this project, we're going to build
an investing strategy that selects the 50
stocks with the best value metrics. From there,
we will calculate recommended trades for equal
weight portfolio of these 50 stocks. So like
before, the first thing that we need to do
is import the open source Python libraries
that we'll be using throughout our Jupyter
Notebook. So it's going to be the same libraries
as we use in the last section. So import NumPy
as NP as a quick recap, NumPy is a numerical
computing library that you need to work with
pandas, and then we'll need to import pandas
as PD, then we'll need to import XLS x writer,
this is the module that we use to save our
pandas data frame as an Excel file at the
end of this Jupyter Notebook, we're going
to import the requests library which is used
for making HTTP requests. You'll recall from
our first project that the slogan for requests
is HTTP for humans, which I quite like. And
then we're also going to need to import the
stats module of Sai pi. Pi import stats. And
the last thing we're gonna need to import
is the math module. So let's run this code
cell to to import all of these libraries into
our Python script. Great, that's done. The
next thing we need to do is import our list
of stocks and our API token. So just like
before, we're going to import our list of
stocks into a panda's data frame called stocks.
And we're also going to import our is cloud
token from our secrets file. So let's do that.
First, we'll say stocks equals PD dot read
underscore, CSV. And then we're gonna type
in SP and hit tab to autocomplete the file
name. Let's just print this to make sure that
it is working like we intend. So this is a
list of all the stocks, and this is a panda's
data frame, you can get the pandas series
that's associated with the only column that
data frame by parsing out the ticker column.
We'll do that later. And the other thing we
need to do here is say from secrets, import,
and then if you just hit tab here, it'll give
you some options. What we want is this is
cloud API token. Great. So that is how we
import our list of stocks and API tokens.
And in the next session, we're gonna make
our first API call using our AI x cloud token.
Great. So like before, what we need to do
now is figure out which end point of the is
cloud API that we need to hit. So I said in
the introduction to this project, that we're
going to start by building a simple value
strategy that screens for stocks based on
a single value metric, and that value metric
is going to be the price to earnings ratio.
Now, for anyone who's not familiar with a
company's price earnings ratio, it's basically
you take their stock price, and you divide
it by how much earnings you expect them to
have over the next year. So as a basic example,
let's say we'll look at Apple again. So Apple's
current stock price is $508.06. Now, if you
wanted to calculate a price to earnings ratio
for Apple, we need to find an earnings estimate.
So we'll just type Apple earnings estimate.
And it looks like these are all quarterly
estimates. And we want an annual estimate.
So whenever you're calculating a price earnings
ratio, or any other kind of valuation metric,
you always use annual numbers in the denominator.
So looks like this chart from NASDAQ provides
some estimated earnings metrics. So yearly
earnings forecast, this is what we want. And
we will use the fiscal year ending in September
2021. It looks like they have consensus earnings
per share of $16 per share. And that means
that to calculate the price earnings ratio,
we just calculate the take the company's current
stock price and divided by 16. So what does
this give us 31. So that means Apple's price
earnings ratio is 31. That's some high level
background on what the price earnings ratio
is. Fortunately, I x cloud makes it very easy
to access price earnings ratios, because if
you go to their documentation, they actually
provide the price earnings ratio natively
here. So we'll just start by trying to control
f find it price to earnings. And it looks
like we have it right here. So P e ratio in
this API endpoint refers to the price earnings
ratio. Oh, I don't know what that was a link
in here somewhere. I clicked the epic timestamp
there. So anyways, P e ratio refers to the
price to earnings ratio for the company. Do
you know what endpoint is this? This is the
quote endpoint. Now this is good because one
of the other things that we'll need for this
screener is we're going to need the latest
stock price for the company. So you look in
the JSON response here. You'll notice that
they have latest price here. And they also
have down at the bottom p e ratio. So what
we're going to do is We're going to take this
API endpoint, we're going to copy it into
our Jupyter Notebook. And we are going to
go back to the sandbox mode here and get our
base URL for every API call that we're going
to make. So here is the sandbox base URL,
we're going to copy that, move it back here,
put it there. And you'll recall from the first
project that we actually have to add stable
here to show that Oh, whoops, was stable and
show that we want the latest stable version
of the API. And not any kind of bleeding edge
version of the API that might have beta features
that aren't fully tested yet. So this is going
to be kind of a sample API endpoint that we'll
use to get our price to earnings ratio, we're
going to call this API URL, and we're going
to make it a string. Now, we need to make
two small changes to this. First of all, we're
going to take this field off yet, because
we don't actually want to parse a single metric
out of this endpoint, we want to parse the
entire JSON response, we're going to leave
symbol there, but we're going to turn this
into an F string so that that symbol actually
becomes interpolated. Now, we need to make
a symbol variable here, and we're gonna say
the symbol is Apple. And the next thing we
need to do is create an actual API call using
the requests library. So to do that, we're
gonna say data equals requests dot get. And
then inside of this get method, we're going
to pass in this API underscore URL. And then
we are going to print out the status code
of this HTTP request. Now, we've talked about
this before, but status codes tell you whether
your HTTP request was successful or not. Successful
HTTP request will return a status code of
200. And most erroneous HTTP requests will
return a status code that's somewhere in the
400 range. So 500 is actually also an indicator.
So we're gonna do a print statement that prints
out data dot status underscore code. And if
this gives us 200, then we know that our first
API call was executed correctly. Alright,
so this gives us 400. And the reason why I've
done this actually before in this course,
but I forgot to add on our authentication
token. So to do that, we're just going to
interpolate in this question mark token equals
and then, inside these curly brackets, we're
going to add our AI x cloud API token. And
this gives us a status code of 200. Awesome.
Now, we'll transform this data variable into
a JSON object using the JSON method, which
accepts no parameters. And then we can print
out this JSON response to see what it actually
contains. Okay, so you can see that it has
a number of different data points available
in this HTTP response, including symbol company
name, primary exchange calculation price,
a whole bunch of other stuff, you can see
actually, since we're using sandbox mode,
this primary exchange quite owns, that's not
a real Stock Exchange, it looks like they
actually just took the company's real exchange,
which is NASDAQ, spelt like this, and SBA
Q, and then they scrambled it or it looks
like they scrambled it somehow. Anyway. So
that's kind of an interesting part of using
the the sandbox mode of the if cloud API.
So what we want to do here is this latest
price endpoint, and this P ratio endpoint
here. So we'll parse out both of those variables
in the next code cell. Okay, so the first
thing we want to do is calculate it with the
stock price. So we'll say price equals data.
And then this is just a Python dictionary,
you can actually verify that by just printing
out its type like this, this will give us
some debt. Yeah, it's a class of debt. So
we'll pick up that print statement. Since
it's a Python dictionary, you can you can
access the value stored in the dictionary,
bypassing the keys and using square brackets.
We've seen this earlier in this course. But
it's always good to have a good little refresher.
So the two things we want our latest price.
So we'll we'll assign that to the price variable.
And let's just print it to make sure it was
parsed out correctly. 513 89. That's awesome.
The other thing we want is price earnings
ratio. So we'll say P e ratio equals data.
And then we're going to parse out this P e
ratio string here. And just like we did with
price, we're going to print this out to make
sure that it is working properly. The ratio
39.6, you can see that this is a little bit
higher than the 31 pe that we calculated manually.
And that's probably because i x cloud is using
a different kind of earnings. One of the tricky
things about running any kind of value strategy
quantitatively like this is that when you're
using earnings or any kind of other fundamental
metric, there are numerous different ways
that it can be calculated. You can use earnings
estimates, which is what I did in my example,
you can also use trailing earnings, which
some people believe are more reliable because
they're actually reported earnings instead
of relying on someone's estimate. But if you
ever calculate a P e ratio, and you're confident
that your math is right, but it doesn't match
someone else's math, the reason why it's probably
because they're defining ratio slightly differently.
So when you're doing any kind of work like
this in the future, it's always good practice
to strictly define what you're doing. So if
you're using trailing earnings, say, I'm using
trailing earnings, and I'm calculating my
P e ratio, if you're using forward earnings,
you might want to call it a forward p e ratio
instead of just p e ratio so that it removes
that ambiguity. Alright, so like before, we
can now move on to executing a batch API call.
And just like I did in the momentum strategy
for this course, I've actually provided some
reusable code that we have used earlier on,
so that you don't actually have to kind of
redundantly write the same code over and over
again, although if you're up for the practice,
what you could do is just delete this entire
code cell and try to write our chunks function
and our symbol strings variable from scratch.
So for now, for the sake of brevity, I'm going
to just run this code cell and proceed with
executing our batch API call. So actually,
before I do that, I'll give you a quick quick
recap of what's going on here. So first off
this, this comment at the top just tells you
where I source this chunks function from.
Since I didn't write this myself, it's always
good to attribute a function to wherever you
received if it's someone else's work. So what
does this chunks function actually do? This
chunks function takes in a list, which is
this LST. And it also takes in this variable
n. And what it does is it you can see in the
doc string here that a yield successive any
size chunks from lists. And to be more specific,
if you have a list of 505, like is, which
is what we're going to pass in, it will return
five lists of n sorry, you pass in a list
of 505 and a value of n of 100, it will pass
you back a list that is five entries of length
101 entry of length five. So that's what that
is. Next step, we create a list using this
chunks variable that takes all of our stocks
and divides them into five lists of length
101, length of list five, and then we create
an empty symbol strings list. And then with
this for loop, we take every group of stocks
that's in the symbol groups variable, and
we create a comma separated string that has
all of the tickers from each list. And if
you want to see what those look like, we can
actually uncomment this print statement and
run this code down. So you can see, this is
one list. This is another list. This is the
next list. This is the end of the fourth,
this is the end of the fifth. And this is
the entire fifth list, which is shorter, because
it wasn't long enough to actually fill out
the length of 100 that was specified by the
function. Okay. And then the last thing that's
done in this code cell is we specify the columns
for our panda's data frame. So the columns
are ticker price, price earnings ratio, and
number of shares to buy. So I'm going to run
this again, with this print statement commented
out to remove that large print. Okay, we can
now move on to writing code from scratch.
So the first thing that we want to do is to
create a blank panda's data frame. And we
saw how to do that we're going to call it
final data frame. And we're going to assign
it a value of PD dot data frame. And within
this class instantiation, we're going to pass
in columns equals my underscore columns. Now,
we saw before that we could have just called
this columns, but then you have columns equals
columns, and that can be a bit unreadable.
So this is what we're going to do to make
sure that that data frame was created properly,
we're going to print it out. And as you can
see, it is an empty panda's data frame with
four columns. And the column names are the
four names that we specified in this list
in the previous code cell. So now that that's
done, what we need to do is we need to loop
over every symbol string in our symbol, strings,
object. And to do that, we're going to say
for symbol string in single strings. And then
we need to actually create another loop inside
of here, that loops over every ticker in that
symbol string. So we're gonna say, for symbol
and symbol, underscore string dot split. And
you'll recall from the last two projects that
if we call this split method, what it does
is it basically does the opposite of this
join method that we saw in the last code cell.
So this is where it's going to be. And then
we're just going to print out a symbol. And
this will allow us to make sure that we're
actually iterating over every symbol in our
universe. Great. So it goes all the way from
a and this should go to z because these are
in order. Yep, all the way down to z. So that
looks like it's working. Okay. Alright, so
within the first for loop, but outside of
the second for loop, we're going to create
a variable, we're going to call that variable
batch API calls URL. And what is this going
to be, it's going to be a URL that is a string,
and it's going to be an F string. And it's
going to query this endpoint that we use earlier,
this quote endpoint for every stock in our
universe. And it's going to do that in batch
API calls for 100 stocks at a time now, to
get the proper syntax. for that. We're going
to go back to the AI x cloud docs, and we're
going to search for batch API. Call. Another
week off with anything. So I'm just going
to search for batch. And here you can see
batch requests. Now, I'm going to scroll down
here to this example, which is what we copied
in the past, I'm going to copy the link address,
I'm going to go back to my Jupyter Notebook.
I'm going to paste that in here. And then
we have to make a few modifications. So the
first thing we want to change is the symbols.
And all we're going to do here is we're going
to actually change them into an interpolated
value. This interpolated value should be symbol
underscore string. Now, what is that symbol
string variable, it is the iterator of this
first for loop. So it will be if you uncomment
this and run this. This is one example of
such a simple string that you can interpolate
into that API called URL. So we'll comment
that out and run it again. Great. So there's
a few other changes that we have to make to
this batch API call URL. One of the first
things is that if you look at the types of
API endpoints that we're hitting here, we
have, quote, we have news and we have chart,
we actually only need the quote endpoint.
So let's take away all the other ones. Awesome.
And then there's two other parameters specified
here, range and last. And we don't need either
of those. So we can take them both off and
replace them with our token equals is called
URL. All right, so let's just run this to
make sure that that's formatted properly.
And instead of this print statement, we're
going to comment it out and just replace it
with a pass keyword. Oops, ignore that. Alright,
so we're going to replace this with a pass
keyword. Great. So that ran properly, which
indicates that the syntax is okay. Now, it's
time for us to actually, so we've created
our API call URL, but we haven't actually
executed the HTTP request yet. And that's
what we'll do next. So to do that, we're going
to use the requests library to execute a get
request. And we're going to store that response
in a variable called data. So data equals
requests. Press dot get, and we're going to
pass in batch API call URL. And then we're
going to call the JSON method on that, actually,
no, we're just going to leave it as is. And
we're going to print data dot status, underscore
code for each one. Now, since there's six
entries in our list, if everything's working
properly, then this should print 206 times
we get 403 for each one. Now, this is actually
interesting. So I mentioned earlier that 405
100 codes and when I say 400, to 500, codes,
I don't mean exactly 400. And exactly 500.
I mean, anything from 400, to 499. And anything
from 500 to 599. These are generally indicate
error. So let's go look exactly what type
of error This is. Um, so type HTTP, or three,
run a search. And Wikipedia is actually pretty
good resource for this. It says the HTTP four
three is an HTTP status code, meaning access
to the requested resources forbidden for some
reason. Now, this is a very, very specific
HTTP response, that usually means that you
have you're not entering the proper API token.
And I'll show you exactly why that is, I know
what they're looking because we didn't change
this cloud keyword to sandbox. If we do that
again, and run it, we should get six 200 codes.
Awesome. 123456. Great. So the next thing
we need to do is actually parse the data and
using an append method, add it to the final
data frame. So we've seen this before, what
we need to do is add that here, we'll take
away this print statement in the past keyword.
And then we'll say, final underscore data
frame, equals file underscore data frame dot
append. And then within this append method,
we need to create a panda's series. We've
seen this before. And within that kind of
series, we need to create a Python list. So
what goes inside this Python list we need?
Basically, one data point for every column,
we need ticker price price earnings ratio
and the number of shares to buy. So we'll
say symbol. That's our ticker, we'll say data.
And then we'll parse out the latest price
data point and then we'll say data and we'll
parse out the PE ratio data point. And then
for the number of shares to buy, we will parse
out nothing and just say and under n slash
a. Now for this panda series, we have to specify
what the indexes will say index equals my
columns. This tells the append method, which
columns of the panda's data frame need to
be considered when you're appending it each
time, so that's very important. And then we
also need to add nor underscore index. Alright,
so if we run this code sell now and then print
out our final data frame, we should get a
data frame that has 505 rows, and each row
corresponds to one stock with the four metrics
that we selected. So with any luck, it should
run six And we're getting response object
is not so scriptable. I'll show you what the
problem is here. When we ran our HTTP request,
we didn't do dot JSON and to actually turn
it into a Python dictionary. So if we run
this now that should be fixed. Latest price.
Oh, I grossly oversimplified the person here.
So since this is a batch API call, we actually
need to do multiple levels of parsing. The
first is symbol. The second is which input
we want to hit. So if we add that to both
of these parses, we should be okay. Alright,
so here's our data frame, it goes from index
zero to index 504, which indicates that all
505 stocks have been successfully added. And
it has four columns ticker price, price to
earnings ratio, and the number of shares to
buy. So now that that's done, we can move
on to removing glamor stocks. Alright, so
now we need to remove the glamour stocks from
our panda's data frame. And for anyone who's
not familiar with the term glamour stock,
it's basically the term that's used to describe
the opposite of a value stock. So if a stock
ranks very poorly on value metrics, then instead
of being called a non value sock or something
like that, it's just called the glamour stock.
Now, since the goal of this strategy is to
identify the 50 best value stocks from our
universe, our next step is to remove glamor
stocks from the DataFrame. And to do this
will kind of follow similar logic as we did
before, we're going to sort the panda's data
frame such that the stocks with the lowest
price earnings ratios are at the top, and
then we're going to remove all of the entries
from the data frame except for stocks that
have that fall below the top 50 in that ranking
scheme. So let's do that. The first thing
we need to do is start the panda's data frame.
And to do that, we will say, final data frame,
dot sort underscore values. Now, you'll recall
that this is the exact same method applied
to the panda's data frame that we use to store
values in the momentum strategy section of
this course. And then what we want to pass
in first is the column that we want to start
out and that is price to earnings ratio, I
just tried to do a tab autocomplete and it
didn't work. So what I'm going to do is just
go up here and copy this. That means I don't
have to worry about making sure I get the
capitalization rate everything. The next thing
we need to do is specify the ascending parameter.
Now we want it to be descending, which means
that sending is equal to false. And the last
thing we need to say is in place equals true.
This parameter tells Panis that instead of
just returning a modified data frame, we want
to modify the original data frame, let's print
out the final data frame object to see if
this worked correctly. So as you can see,
we have a price earnings ratio of 2400 at
the top and a price earnings ratio of not
the bottom, I actually did this correctly,
this should be true. Now we see that our lowest
values are at the top and our highest values
are at the bottom. Now one important thing
to note with this is that since ascending
defaults, having a true value, we can actually
remove this completely. And it'll give it
the same output. As you see. Another thing
that's worth mentioning is that all of the
stocks that have negative price to earnings
ratios. If you think about the mathematical
definition of the price earnings ratio, it's
price divided by earnings. So in order for
price to earnings ratio to have a negative
value than either price has to be negative
or earnings has to be negative. Now, stocks
can't actually have a negative price. So what
this means is that these stocks have negative
earnings, there is kind of a wide body of
evidence to say that you might not want to
invest in stocks that have negative earnings.
So in a real investment strategy, you may
want to remove all stocks that have negative
price earnings ratios. And one easy way to
do that would be something like this final
data frame such that final data frame at the
price to earnings ratio column is greater
than zero. Now what is this return should
return the final data frame with all of the
negative values removed. So we're going to
include this and to actually modify the original
data frame, we have to assign it, you'll notice
that if we print this, this gives us the final
data frame with negative values. So what we're
going to do is take this out, we're gonna
say final data frame is equal to that. And
then we need to return just the top 50 stocks
according to this order schema. We saw how
to do that in the momentum project of this
course. But it's pretty easy. You just say
final data frame is equal to final underscore
data frame. And then you want to access out
with square brackets colon 50. Now if we print
this, it should be a data frame that ranges
from zero to 50. Okay, so this looks good
to me. There's a couple things we can do to
make sure that this is working properly. We
can print its length, this should be 50. Awesome.
And then the last thing we want to do is reset
its index so that the index actually runs
from zero to 50. So we'll do we underscore
index in this give us. Alright, as you can
see, this now goes from zero to 49, which
means there's 50 entries in the panda's data
frame, the only other thing we need to do
is get rid of this new index column, we saw
one way to do it in the last section of this
course, I'm gonna show you a different way
now. First, we're, one thing I've read here
is going to stay in place equals true within
this. And that means that the reset index
method will actually modify the original data
frame. Now, if we print this out, again, we
should see the modified data frame. Awesome.
And since I ran this twice, we actually have
two separate reset indices. So let's go back
up here. And we'll rerun this, we run this
and we run this and we should just have one
duplicate index. Okay. What we want to do
now is we're going to call the draw method,
we're going to pass in the index column, we're
also going to pass in in place equals true
here, what does this give us? It gives us
a key error because index is not found in
axis. Okay? The drop method, by definition
automatically acts on rows not on columns.
So to change that, we have to say x equals
one. What is this give us cannot insert level
underscore zero, it exists, that's because
we already ran that cell. So if we run this
now what happens? Alright, everything looks
to appears to have worked properly. So we'll
print this out again to make sure it looks
good. Awesome. So now let's just do a quick
recap of what we learned in this section.
I explained briefly what a glamor stock is,
we sorted our final data frames such that
the stocks with the lowest price earnings
ratios were at the top of the data frame,
and we specified the in place equals true
parameters so that the original data frame
was actually modified. And it didn't just
return a modified data frame. So that's what
that line does. Next up, we, we sorted the
data frames such that all rows that have a
price to earnings ratio value below zero were
dropped from the data frame, then we trim
the data frame to only include the stocks
with the 50 lowest price earnings ratios,
we reset the index, and then we drop the new
index column that was created by way of this
reset index method. Now, one important thing
to note about this is that we could have actually
specified the drop parameter here to do the
same thing. That's what we did in the last
section. But the reason why I showed you this
method instead, is just to reinforce the idea
that whenever you're doing any kind of software
development, there's usually multiple different
ways to solve a given problem. So that's that,
Let's now move on to calculating the number
of shares that we need to buy. Just like we
did in the momentum strategy section of this
course, we're going to use the portfolio input
function to do this. And to make things easy
for you, I actually included the portfolio
input function there, I encourage you to try
to delete that formula and recreate it from
scratch, scratch, if you want the extra practice.
For now, I'm just going to run this. And then
I'm going to use the portfolio input function
to accept a portfolio size variable. So let's
do that. And I'm going to test here that the
try accept value error statement is working
by putting in a string, so I'm going to say
my portfolio is $1 million. And then if I
enter this, then it should print it. That's
not a number of try again. Awesome. Now I
can say $1 million, so that six zeros 123456.
Awesome. The next thing we need to do is calculate
the position size. So just like we did before,
position size can be calculated by dividing
the portfolio size by the number of shares
in the portfolio. So we're going to position
size divided by the length of our final data
frame. And you can take any column of this
data frame to find its length, I'm going to
use the index and there's no kind of right
or wrong answer here. I just the index is
what I typically use for this. So that's that,
and this position size should be $20,000,
I believe. Now here it says type error unsupported
operand type. That's because this portfolio
size, despite it actually being a number,
it's still formatted as a string, so we need
to wrap it in a float function. This gives
us $20,000. Awesome. Now we need to loop through
the every row in the panda's data frame, and
modify the value that's contained in the number
of shares to buy column. So to do that, we're
going to say for row in in final data frame
dot index, and then we are going to say, final
data frame dot LSE. This is the exact same
method that we used to modify this before.
We're going to do row and then number of shares
to buy. Then we're going to use the assignment
operator to say divide that stocks or sorry
to divide our position, size by that stocks
stock price. So We put pricing here. That
should be the trick. Now we'll print out our
final data frame to make sure that this is
operating correctly. This looks good. Let's
just compare two stocks here. So we have a
stock at $35 and a stock at $18. So this is
interesting, because this is roughly double
this. So this should be roughly double this,
and it kind of passes the eyeball test. So
that's good. Now, the only other thing we
need to add here is the floor function. So
as you'll recall from the last section of
or the last project of this course, you can
usually buy fractional shares at some brokers.
So if we wrap this in the floor function,
it will give us the closest lower integer
to the number of shares that are calculated.
So if we run this, we can see that those have
all been transformed to integers. Awesome.
We are now ready to move on to building a
better and more realistic value strategy.
All right, so it is now it's time for us to
build a better and more realistic value strategy.
Now, just like in the momentum project that
we built earlier in this course, what we're
going to do to make a better value strategy
is to build a strategy that takes into account
many different metrics. And the reason why
that makes the strategy better is because
every valuation metrics tend to have certain
flaws. For example, as we saw earlier in this
project, the price to earnings ratio doesn't
exactly work that well with stocks that have
negative earnings. Similarly, another popular
valuation metric is the price to book value
ratio. And that ratio doesn't work well with
stocks that perform a bunch of share buybacks.
So there's lots of different things to consider
for every valuation metric. And one common
way that investment managers reduce any of
the flaws, reduce the impact of any specific
valuation metrics flaws, is by creating value
strategies that take into account a compensated
value. So instead of just saying, we're going
to rank stocks on price to earnings ratio,
they rank percentiles for a bunch of different
valuation metrics, and then rank stocks according
to the average of those percentile scores.
So that's exactly what we're gonna do in this
section. Here are all the ratios we consider.
So price to earnings ratio, we already saw
that price to book ratio. Now, this is the
company's stock price, the company's stock
price divided by its shareholders equity per
share, the price to sales ratio, this is the
company's stock price divided by its revenue
per share enterprise value divided by EBITDA.
Now, that is a more complicated valuation
metric, even R stands for earnings before
interest, taxes, depreciation, amortization,
enterprise value is basically the number that
you would have to pay to buy out the company
in full. So that doesn't just mean buying
it all at a stock, you would have to also
buy it all of his debt and any minority shareholdings
that exists. So that's what enterprise value
is. And then another column valuation metric
is enterprise value divided by gross profit.
So all of these five valuation metrics, we're
going to now pull in from the i x cloud API.
Now to do that, we're going to start by just
making a single API call. And then we will
loop through that same API call for a bunch
of different stocks that are listed in our
stock data structure to build a panda's data
frame that contains all the data. So to start,
we'll just do this for one symbol, and that
symbol is going to be apple. And then we're
going to do a batch API call here. And unlike
before, we're not going to use a batch API
call because we want to query the i x cloud
API for multiple symbols. But instead, we
have to do use a batch API call because we're
querying the API for multiple endpoints. So
since the different valuation measures listed
here are all so different, they're not all
actually going to be stored in the same endpoint.
So we need to find where they are in the iOS
prod API, and then add those endpoints to
a batch API call URL. So let's start by just
creating the variable batch API call URL.
And just like before, this is going to be
an F string. Now let's to make this easy,
we're just going to base this off of the batch
API calls that we executed earlier in this
project. So let's scroll up and find that.
Alright, so here is where it is, I am going
to highlight all of this and copy it to my
clipboard, I'm going to scroll back down to
where we were just working and paste this
in. Okay, now, we have to make a few changes
here. The first is that we need to replace
this symbol string with just symbol. And then
let's actually execute an API call against
this to make sure that it's working properly.
So we've seen this many times by now. But
we're going to do data equals and then to
define the variable we're going to say requests
dot get, and then we're going to pass in that
batch API call URL, not the data URL, batch,
API call URL. And then let's do print data
dot status underscore code. And if this returns
200, then we know it's working correctly.
That is all Okay, so let's go through all
of these metrics one by one, I'm actually
going to copy these, and paste them down here
and comment them all out. Oops, sorry not
to do. There we go. And then underneath each
of these comments, we're actually going to
parse that value from the IRS cloud API. So
the first thing we need to do is get the price
earnings ratio. And we actually saw how to
do this in the last section of this tutorial.
So if you go back up here, we are going to
go to where we copied this original batch
API call URL. And we are just going to grab
this parse here. So it's data and then symbol,
and then quote, and then PE ratio. So let's
copy that and scroll back down to where we
were just working, which is right here. And
if we print this, this should give us what
we need. Okay, now we're getting this error
response object is not subscript well, and
that's because I haven't called the JSON method
on our API call. So we're going to add that
here. And then we're going to remove this
data status code, because that's now going
to return an error. Let's run this code cell
again. Great. So this tells us that Apple
has a current price earnings ratio of 38.84,
according to the i x cloud API. Let's now
assign this variable to it for this value
to a variable called PE ratio. And we're going
to do similar things down here. So PB ratio
is going to be pairs to book ratio. And for
now, we're just going to assign that a value
of not a number. So this is a not a number
data structure that's stored within the NumPy
library. If you've never seen that before,
in order to do a P, or sorry, p s ratio, same
thing, np dot n a n. And then down here, we're
going to do Evie to either that same thing,
np.na n. And then we're going to do Evie to
gross profit, Evie to gross profit equals
np.mn. Okay, we've now filled these all with
placeholder values of NP dot and n. Let's
now go into the IRS cloud docs, and figure
out where these data points are contained
within the i x cloud API. So just like before,
all I did for this was I Google is cloud docs.
And it's the first non add, hit clicking.
Alright, so now I'm going to do a Ctrl F search
for PB. and with any luck, this will show
us where the price to book ratio is held.
There were seven hits, I just searched through
all of them. I didn't, it wasn't any of them.
So now I'm going to track the price to book
it only gets two hits. And both of those hits
are this value score, which looks like it's
its own composite metric here. So let's try
price to book with hyphens. There we go price
to book, what endpoint is this. So this is
the advanced stats endpoint. And to add that
to our batch API call URL, I'm just going
to copy it. And I'm going to add it here right
after the quote. So comma advanced stats.
So now we are going to print our data object
and see what we have to parse out. So do that.
Alright, so we're gonna have to do multiple
levels of parsing here, we're going to print
data, Apple. And then within that, we are
going to parse out the advanced stats endpoint.
Alright, so now when we run this code sale,
this will show us what's contained inside
the advanced tests endpoint, we want PB ratio.
So I'm going to do a Ctrl F for PB here and
see if it highlights anything. I don't see
it there. So I'm going to do a Ctrl F for
book. And I see it right there. So price to
book. Now we can copy this in and parse it
out. Alright, so this tells us that Apple
has a current price to book ratio of 23.8.
I'm going to copy this and assign it to our
variable of PB underscore ratio. Then what
I'm going to do is I'm going to remove the
final section of parsing from this line, I'm
going to print out the JSON object again,
and I'm going to try to find the price to
sales ratio. So just like before, I will start
by saying PS. There is one hit within this
data structure, but it's TTM ups. If you've
never seen that before, all that stands for
is trailing 12 months earnings per share.
And that's no and that's not what we want.
So I'm going to do a Ctrl F search again for
sales. And you can see right here, we have
price to sales ratio. Awesome. So I'm going
to do is I'm going to copy this price to book
ratio data point and instead of price to book,
I'm going to change this to price to sales.
And then I'm going to print the PS ratio so
that we can see what value we get. So this
tells us at the bottom here, that Apple has
a current price to sales ratio of $8.20, or
sorry, 8.28. So I can delete that. Now we
have to parse out enterprise value to EBITDA,
and enterprise value to gross profit. Now,
both of these are a little more complex, but
we can still make it work. The reason they're
more complex is because the V to EBIT ratio
and the EB to gross profit ratio, they aren't
actually provided explicitly by the IAS cloud
API. Instead, we're going to have to pull
in their constituent metrics. So enterprise
value, and Eva, or enterprise value and gross
profit respectively. And then we're going
to have to do the division ourselves. So to
start, let's try and find enterprise value,
we'll create a variable called enterprise
value. And to start we'll assign that a value
of np.na n. And then we're going to want to
do a Ctrl F search within this endpoint for
enterprise. And, interestingly enough, the
ice cloud API does provide one of the enterprise
multiples, but its enterprise value to revenue,
which is not one of the ones we're going to
use. So instead, we're going to pull in this
enterprise value. And point, we're going to
grab this for price to sales, and we're going
to copy it down to the enterprise value variable,
and then replace this with enterprise value.
And then let's print it now since Apple is
a very large company, this enterprise value
should be huge. Yeah, it looks like it's more
than 2 trillion if I'm just eyeballing it
there. Actually, let's divide that by trying
to see if I'm right one, and then we should
be nine zeros 12345678. Sorry, not nine zeros,
12 zeros. So in three more 123. And it looks
like it's around $2.2 trillion of enterprise
value for Apple right now, which is pretty
crazy. Alright, so we have our enterprise
value. Now we need our EDA, let's do a Ctrl
F search for Eva, and see if it pops up in
this endpoint. You can see right there that
it is pretty easy to access, what we'll do
is we'll just copy this, paste it there, or
change the variable name to Eva, and then
change the parsing to Eva as well. It's all
capitals, so make sure you capitalize this
as you're working through it. And then for
our Evie to EBIT ratio, what we're just going
to do is say enterprise underscore value divided
by and that ran correctly, what we need to
do now is printed to see what value we're
actually storing Evie to EBIT. So this tells
us that Apple has a current Evie to EBIT ratio
of 28.2. Awesome. So using this information,
we can now proceed to calculating our Evie
to gross profit, we already have our enterprise
value, and it's sort of a variable up here.
So what we need to do now is create a variable
called gross profit and parse out the gross
profit number from this from this JSON object.
So to do that, I'm going to do a Ctrl F search
for gross. And you can see the gross profit
metric is right there. So what I'm going to
do is copy the parsing that we did for our
EBIT variable earlier in this Kotel, I'm going
to paste it here. And then I'm going to replace
the image parsing with a gross profit parsing.
Now if we print out gross profit, what does
it give us? This shows you that Apple had
gross profit of I'm going to say that's 10
billion, I'm not really sure, just by looking
at it, there's no commas, which makes it a
little harder to read. Anyways, the numbers
being pulled out successfully, that's the
main thing. So now what we're going to do
is say Evie, to gross profit is equal to enterprise
value, divided by gross profit. And then we
will print this on the next line print, Evie
to gross profit. And I'm actually gonna run
this code set again with that statement. So
this shows us that Apple has an end to gross
profit ratio of 22.6. Okay, so we've now done
all of the parsing and calculations that we
need to get all of our value metrics for one
stock. Now it's time for us to generalize
this logic and build a panda's data frame
that stores all of this information. So we'll
do that next. Now, you'll see in the header
for this code sale that he says you'll notice
that I use the abbreviation RV often and that's
what we're going to use for robust value,
which is kind of the name I'm going to use
for this investment strategy. It's kind of
the equivalent to high quality momentum that
we use in the last project. So as before,
the first thing we need to do is say RV underscore
columns. And then we need to create a Python
list that defines all of the columns that
we're going to use in our panda's data frame.
So the first thing will be ticker that's the
stock ticker of the company we're looking
at. The next thing will be price and that
is the stock price of the company we're looking
at. The next thing is number of shares to
buy Just like in our first two projects that
tells our trader team how many shares of the
specific security to buy when they're rebalancing.
And now we're going to start working through
all of our valuation metrics. So more specifically,
we're going to say, price to earnings ratio.
And then we're going to say a percentile score
for price earnings ratio. So we'll call that
P e percentile. And then we're going to we
need a column for our price to book ratio,
so price to book ratio. And then we need a
column for the percentile score of price to
book so PB percentile. And then we need a
column for our price to sales ratio. So that's
the price to sales ratio. And then we need
price to actually we'll say p s percentiles,
and that matches the abbreviation that we
use for our first two percentile scores. And
then we need enterprise value divided by Earnings
Before Interest taxes, depreciation amortization.
So So for that, we're just to bring it right
from the get go because it's quite long. And
we will say, Evie, to EBIT, da. And then on
the next line, we will do a percentile score
for that metric. So Evie to EBIT. percentile.
And then we need our Evie to gross profit.
So we'll say Eb to GP and then Eb two, Eb
to gross profit percentile. The last thing
we need to do is calculate our robots value
score. So we'll do that right from the get
go, this time, our RB score, awesome, I'm
gonna run this code sale just to make sure
that the syntax here is all working, that
is awesome, we can now move on to creating
an empty panda's data frame. So we'll call
this data frame RV data frame. And that stands
for robust value data frame. And to associate
it we're gonna say, PD data frame. And then
inside of this class call, we're going to
say columns equals RV underscore columns.
And what does that look like? It doesn't look
like anything because I didn't check it out
yet. So let's add RV DataFrame on the last
line. And as you can see, this has all of
the columns that we specified, and we are
ready to start creating our loop. Now, we
have already created our symbol strings object
earlier in this project. So if you scroll
up here, a little further, what am I looking
for? Here is so this code cell was already
provided when you guys open this up. And this
is created simple strings that we can loop
through when creating our data frame. So we
don't have to do that, again, because those
variable values are already stored in this
Jupyter Notebook. So we're ready to create
the loop. All we need to do now is say, for
symbol string in symbol strings, and to make
sure this is looping correctly, let's just
print out the single string. Awesome, that
looks good. And then within this loop, we
have to create our batch API call. And we're
gonna do that in the same way that we did
before, we're first gonna create the URL.
And then once the URL has been created, we're
going to use our requests library to actually
execute the HTTP request. So we'll call the
URL batch API call URL. And then we already
created this URL a few cells earlier. So we
can just go up to here and copy this with
a few minor changes. So the minor changes
I was referring to are that we have to replace
this symbol with symbol string, and that it
should be good to go. To make sure this is
working properly. I'm just going to print
the batch API call URL. Let's see what happens.
Awesome. You can test easily whether any of
these is working by just clicking on and what
that will do is in a separate browser window,
it will open up the JSON object that you'll
be pulling in. So let's see, awesome in a
browser window like this, this is pretty useless,
because you can't really manipulate it. But
that's a quick easy way to tell that your
API calls working right. Now let's execute
our HTTP request. So we're gonna do that in
the exact same way that we did before data
is equal to requests dot get. And then inside
that get method pass in batch. API, call the
URL. And then we're going to print out data
dot status code. And since we already clicked
on the URL to open up the JSON object in a
separate tab a few moments ago, we know that
these API calls are working. But printing
the status code is another way you can check
it. So if these API calls are functioning
as we want them to, this should print out
HTTP code of 200 for each API call. So let's
see. 123456 and it should be six. So that
is awesome. All right. So now we're ready
to start parsing our data frame. And to do
that, the first thing you need to do is add
the JSON method to the request dot get method
and what this does is it turns this object
which is a request response object in To a
JSON for us to manipulate. Now, if you print
out the data for each one will be a bunch
of big JSON objects. And this is what we need
to start manipulating. So now that we're in
here, we need to loop through every ticker
within our symbol string, and append the data
for that ticker to our empty panda's data
frame. To do that, we need an inner loop.
And that inner loop will look like this. We'll
say for symbol in symbol, underscore string
dot split. And then we're going to split on
the column character just like we did in the
other two projects. To make sure this is working
properly, let's print out our symbol. Awesome.
So you can see we're going through all of
the symbols in our stocks, panda's data frame
that we created at the very start of this
Jupyter Notebook. And we're printing them
out in alphabetical order. Okay, so now that
that's done, we can start using the append
method to add data to our empty panda's data
frame. And to do that, what we're gonna say
is RV data frame is equal to RV underscore
data frame dot append. Now we're gonna use
same, we're gonna use similar logic inside
of this head method as we've used earlier
in this course. So when you attend a series,
and then inside of that panda's series, we
need a Python list. And we also need to specify
index is equal to RV columns. Now, in case
you're not remembering what this does, this
index equals RV columns specifies which columns
of the empty panda's data frame, each item
of this pandas series should be appended to,
and then inside of the pandas series, we want
to add the ignore index equals true. Now,
I haven't really done a super job explaining
this. But to be very specific, what this does
is it means that every row that you add to
the panda's data frame will have its index
column automatically calculated for you. So
the first row will have index zero, the second
row will have index one, the third row will
have index to the 50th row will have index
49, and so on. So that's what this ignore
index does. Now, within this panda series,
we need to parse out all of these data points.
So like I did in the last project, what I'm
going to do here is I'm actually just going
to copy these in. And since it's a comma separated
list, we can just replace each element of
this list with the data that we want to parse
out. So we'll do that one by one ticker, we
want to replace with symbol. And remember
that symbol is the incrementer of the inner
for loop that we're building here. For price,
we want to parse it with price. And we saw
how to do that up here. That's actually not
true, we didn't see how to do that there.
But what we can do is go back up to our earlier
project where we did this for for just a screener
that only factors in price earnings ratio,
we can copy this parsing that we use here.
So we'll do that and scroll back down here.
And then we want to replace this price with
that awesome. Now number of shares to buy
just like in the in the other projects that
we worked on in this course were replaced
with a placeholder value and a price earnings
ratio we actually parsed in the last code
cell along with all of the other valuation
metrics that we need. So what we can do here
is just say, copy that and add it where the
price earnings ratio is. And then we come
to the section where we need price to earnings
ratio percentile and all of the percentile
scores in this pandas DataFrame, just like
in the ones that we worked with earlier in
this course, we're going to replace them with
a place where the value of na, because in
order to calculate percentiles, you need the
panda's data frame to be fully populated first.
So we will calculate these a little later
on in this project. For now, we're going to
replace them all with an A. And one more.
And for that matter, this robust value score
in the last column also needs here. So let's
do that now to Alright, the next thing we
need is our price to book ratio. And just
like the price to earnings ratio, we had parsed
that out in the last Cosell. So I'm going
to copy that I'm going to add that here. Oh,
sorry, not there, down here. I knew something
was gonna look great. So add that there, we
are going to do the same thing with our price
to sales ratio. So that's right here. All
right now for Evie to even up an Eevee to
gross profit. We actually have to do some
special logic here because there are metrics
that are using both of those calculations
that aren't available for every stock. So
here's how we handle that. The first thing
we need to do is pull in our enterprise value,
or even in our gross profit metrics. And we're
going to do that inside of this append method.
So there's enterprise value. Here's the eba.
And here is gross profit. Awesome. And then
in here, for now, I'm not going to do the
special logic that I just referred to referred
to earlier, because I want to show you what
happens if you go into pptp. Oh, and this
isn't easy as it should be enter price value.
And then here would be enterprise value divided
by gross profit. All right, let's run this
and see what happens. So far, so good 72.
And then that we get a key error for a Pl.
And that's because all of those applets it
says need to be replaced with symbol. Let's
do that. Try that. Great. We have another
key err, because there's more instances of
Apple up here. That is embarrassing. Like
I said earlier in this course, I'm not going
to edit this out, because I want you to see
how I debug stuff in real time, it might be
useful to see the debugging process of a different
developer. Okay, what happens now, here's
what we're getting. So it says unsupported
operand type for division, integer and non
type. And that's referring to this line right
here. Okay, what's going on, let's crank out
our enterprise value. So we have a value for
enterprise value. Now let's print it or EBITDA.
None, now, that is the source of the error.
So to fix this, we need to find some sort
of workaround to fill this value, even when
there's a none type for one of the metrics
that it contains. Now, there's lots of different
ways that you can handle this. But what we're
going to do is this, I'll show you so we saw
when building our portfolio input function
in earlier projects of this course, that tricep
statements can be used to handle exceptions.
So that's what we're going to use, we're gonna
use try this. And if that doesn't work, we're
going to make an accept statement that handles
specifically the type of error one carrying,
which is a type error. And then we're going
to say np.na n now, because this is in an
append statement, we actually can't put it
there. Instead, we're going to create an EV
to EBITDA ratio, and put this outside of the
append state. And I'll show you more about
what that looks like in a second correctly.
Okay, so this is going to be putting aside
the append statement right here after we create
all these. And since the indenting, is in
a loop, I have to tab that in. And then we
will replace this with sorry, Evie, to Eva.
Now, okay, what this does is it tries to calculate
a vd beta using this. And if that fails because
of a type error, then it will fill it in with
NP dot and n. Now, that's not good, because
na N stands for not a number, and how are
you supposed to source logs on value metrics
that aren't numbers? Well, we're going to
see later on in this section, or later on
in this project, I should say that there's
a number of different ways that you can handle
missing data in the pandas library to fill
in the values that aren't there with reasonable
values by performing calculations on the other
values in the data set. So I will see more
about that later. But the main idea to remember
now is that even though we're filling our
panda's data frame with null values, now,
those aren't going to stay there for our final
calculations, because we're going to replace
them with something more meaningful later.
Okay, the next thing we need to do is we haven't
seen it yet. But this type error happens with
the gross profit metric as well because some
companies don't actually report gross profit
depending on how, what their operations look
like and those sorts of things. So what we're
gonna do is create a similar Eb to gross profit
metric here and use the exact same type error
Exception Handling to to handle this, okay,
so Eb to gross profits, enterprise value divided
by gross profit, this looks good. The only
other thing we need to do is take this variable
and replace the actual divisor in the income
statement. Okay, now I'm going to delete this
other code cell that we were working with
and run it again to see if it works. So far,
so good. Awesome, so that code cell ran with
no problem let's print our data frame now
see what it looks like. Awesome. So we have
ticker stock price number of shares to buy
price to earnings ratio, p percentile price
to book ratio, PB percentile, price to sales
ratio.
O p s percentile EV to EBITDA percentile up
to GP percentile and the army score. Everything
looks like it was added properly here. So
we can now move on to dealing with missing
data in our data frame. Now, our data frame
contains missing values, because we use that
try accept logic in the last section to fill
in missing values. Whenever the cloud API
provided a nun response for a metric that
we were using. That's basically what this
says it says our data frame contains some
missing data because all the metrics we require
are not available through the API that we're
using. So to see where this missing data is,
what you can do is use the pandas is no method.
So this is kind of the statement you execute
to see all call or sorry, all the rows that
have missing data, and then you say, RV data
frame, and then in square brackets, you would
say RV data frame is no. And then on that
isn't all you want to say any and then axis
equals one. Okay, so to break this down, we're
taking our RV data frame, and then we are
filtering in the square brackets to say any
part of RV data frame where the is no method
is true. And then on that we want to apply
it to any columns. And this axis equals one
tells us columns, not rows. So when we run
this, this is going to return a modified version
of our panda's data frame that only contains
rows where there's missing data. All right,
so as you can see, there is quite a bit of
missing data. And you can actually see how
much there is by calling the length of this
index. So there's 55 rows that have some sort
of missing data in the panda's data frame,
which is about 10% of the entire data set.
So let's look at this again. As you can see,
all not all of the indices of the panda's
data frame exists. So it starts at 1718 2026.
There's lots of missing rows, because all
the missing rows have no missing data. So
let's take a look at this first row, which
covers the stock Aflac, which is an insurance
company, there is a non value here for price
to sales ratio, there is a nun value. Actually,
that's the only non value for that column.
Now, if you look, in other columns, like this
column, there's a non value for price to earnings
ratio. And overall, these non values aren't
super problematic, because in the next section,
we're going to see how to deal with it. So
this says dealing with that dealing with missing
data is an important topic in data science.
And there's two main approaches, you can either
drop the missing data using the drop na method,
or you can replace the missing data with a
fill in a method. So the following NF, it's
pretty interesting, because you can actually
pass information that allows it to fill in
missing data with summary data from that same
column. So as one example, if we have missing
data in our price to earnings ratio column,
we can fill it in with the average value of
all price earnings ratios for all the other
stocks in the data set. So that's exactly
what we're going to do, we're going to replace
missing data with the average non null data
point from that column. So here's the code.
To do this, we need to create a for loop that
loops over all of the columns in our panda's
data frame. So we'll say for column and RV
underscore data frame dot columns. And then
let's just print this out to see what is happening.
Great. As you can see, this is successfully
looping over our pandas data frames. And then
what we want to say is our V underscore data
frame, dot fill, and a Now if you've never
used this before, one easy way to see which
parameters it accepts is most into the the
parentheses of the method and then hit Shift
Tab. And this will pop up a little bit of
documentation. So what we're going to do is
we're going to say fill in the missing values
with the average value from that column. So
to get the average value, we're going to say,
fill in a and then we're going to say, RV
underscore data frame, we're going to select
that specific column from the data frame.
And then we're going to call the mean method
on dot mean. And one other thing I forgot
to add here is that we don't want to apply
this to the entire data frame, we want to
apply to this specific column on that data
frame. Now, the reason why you have to add
this is because if you didn't, for the first
iteration of this loop, when it loops through
the ticker column, it would fill the entire
data frame with the average value of the ticker
column, which is not what we want. So if we
run this, we get a value error and says cannot
convert string to float. Now, the reason why
this is is because you can't actually, so
what this is doing is it's trying to calculate
a mean for the ticker column, which is obviously
impossible. So we actually need to create
a subset of our columns. And to do that, the
easiest way is probably to just print out
our columns, early data columns. We will grab
in And then we need to modify our for loop
so that it only loops over certain columns
of the panda's data frame. So we will put
that there. And then does this still work
with it being multi line, it does awesome.
So we want to take out all of our non numerical
columns. So that would be all the percentiles
it would be PB percentile, p s percentile,
EV to EBITDA percentile. ebgp percentile,
and are the percentile. And I'm actually going
to take out this Price column too, because
there's not going to be any missing price
data. Alright, so if we run this, this should
look a little better. I'm actually going to
put these all in one line just for readability.
There we go. Alright, what happens when I
run this? Awesome. Now, if we run our same
command from earlier, to identify missing
data in our data frame? If we have done this
properly, this should return an empty data
frame because there shouldn't be any null
values anymore. And there still is why is
that? This price to sales ratio still has
quite a bit of null values. Why is that? Oh,
I see. So within this fill in a method, you
actually have to pass the in place equals
true. And this says, Don't just return the
modified column, modify the original column
instead. So we'll do that. And then when we
run this, we get an empty panda's data frame,
which shows us that we have successfully dealt
with all the missing data in the original
data frame. So that's kind of a high level
introduction of how to deal with missing data
in pandas. There's lots of more information
you could learn about this. And dealing with
missing data is a full topic in and of itself.
So this is just a high level introduction,
we can now move on to calculating value percentiles.
Alright, so what we need to do now is we need
to calculate value score percentiles for every
stock in our universe. More specifically,
we need to calculate percentile scores for
the following metrics, price to earnings ratio,
price to book ratio, price to sales ratio,
Evie to EBIT and Evie to gross profit. Now,
unlike before, we can't use the start of every
string as a way to interpolate in that string.
Because in the last project, we had the same
two words, at the start of every momentum
metric, like an example would be, we had one
year price momentum and one year, return percentile.
So we can't do that anymore, because we use
some abbreviations. So if you look here, you
can't use price to earnings ratio to find
the price earnings ratio percentile column
because there's an abbreviation. So I did
that intentionally so that you can see a different
way of approaching this problem. What we're
going to do instead is I just copied the column
names to my clipboard like this. And we are
going to turn this into a dictionary, we're
going to call this dictionary metrics. And
here's what we're going to do. So we need
to wrap this entire thing in curly brackets.
And for every metric column, that column name
is going to be a key for the dictionary. And
that percentile column is going to be the
value of the dictionary like that. So if we
do that same operation on a few different
lines, this will fill it up pretty quickly.
All right, let's put these on our own lines
like that. Okay, so basically, what this does,
I'm gonna run this code cell to make sure
it's formatted properly. And the way we're
going to use this dictionary is we're going
to pass in a, a metric, and it will return
back the name of the corresponding percentile
row. So to calculate our percentile scores,
we are going to loop through every metric
in this metrics dictionary. So here's how
we'll do that we'll say for metric in metrics,
dot fees. And then within here, we need to
calculate percentile scores. And we need to
do that for every row. So we need to create
an inner loop that says for row in RV underscore
data frame, index, and then here's what we're
gonna do. We're going to print the row now
this should print how many metrics are there
five, five times this should print zero to
504. So we have 12345. Awesome. Okay, now
here we need to use the pandas LLC method
to access the percentile score. columns. Now
here's how we'll do that we'll say RV underscore
data frame, dot LLC. And then the first entry
of this LSE method will be in a row and the
second entry will be the column name. And
that will be metric. No sorry, that won't
be metric that will be metrics have metric.
And this funny looking dictionary access statement
is basically pulling in a percentile column.
To make sure that that's working properly,
let's just print this. And what this should
do is just print a whole bunch of anaise.
Awesome. So this shows that we're accessing
all of the different percentile columns. And
we want to do here is use the percentile of
score to calculate a percentile. So to do
that, we'll say that is equal to stats dot
percentile score. And then within this, we're
gonna have two items. So this will be the
entire column. And this will be the value
of that row at the column. So to get the entire
column, we're just going to say, RV and just
look at the thing. And then we're gonna pass
in the name of the column, so that will be
metric. And then over here, we need an over
here, we want to get the value of the row
at that column. To do that, we're going to
say, RV underscore data frame, LLC. And instead
of saying, the metrics dictionary, at that
metric, we're just gonna say the metric. So
let's run this and then print our panda's
data frame to see what that looks like. Great.
So here, we have all the percentile scores.
Now, you can see this appears to be right,
because here we have a low Evie to GP and
has a low percentile. Here's a high Evie to
GP with a higher percentile. And you can see
the same logic for all of these now, just
like before, this Python line is very long,
and it's actually all fit on one line. So
I'll show you how you can easily make that
a little cleaner. we'll import the function
specific resources from sci fi dot stats,
import, percentile of score as score. And
then we can replace this with just score.
And actually, since we use a different dictionary
method, this now fits on one line is much
more readable. If you run it, they'll give
the same output. Great. So that's how we calculated
our percentile scores. As a quick recap of
what is done in this code cell, we imported
the percentile of score function from the
Sai pi dot stats module, and we named it score.
And then we created a dictionary of metrics
where every key in the dictionary is one of
the valuation metrics that we're using an
every value of the dictionary is the corresponding
percentile column of our panda's data frame.
And then we created a double nested for loop,
where the first for loop loops over every
metric in our metric dictionary, and the second
for loop loops over every row in our panda's
data frame. And then, within both of those
four loops, we have an operation here that
calculates the percentile score of every evaluation
metric and assigns that value to the corresponding
percentile score column. And at the very end,
we just printed out our past data frame. Now
we can move on to calculating our lead score.
So just like before, we're going to use the
mean function from the built in Python stats
module. So we'll say from stats, import name,
and then we're just going to calculate the
mean of five and 10. Make sure that this is
working properly. We say no module name stats,
that's because I should have said statistics
Great. So the mean of five and 10 is indeed
7.5. So that seems to be working properly.
Now what we need to do is we need to loop
through every row of our panda's data frame,
and calculate the the avar calculate the RV
score for that row. So to start, we'll just
say for throw in RV storage data frame index.
And let's just print that row. So this should
print a bunch of numbers from zero to 504.
So it goes zero all the way to 504. That is
excellent. Now, we need to access this row
of the panda's data frame and like before,
we can do that with the LSC method. So what
I'll do is I'll just copy this, paste it here,
and I'll change which column we're accessing
to RV score. And to make sure this is working
properly, let's just print this. Alright,
that looks good. Now what we need to do is
access all of the different percentile scores
from our pandas DataFrame and calculate their
mean. So on this side, we'll say mean and
then since this will be a fairly long line,
I'm actually going to variables for all these.
It's a P e ratio, PB ratio, PS ratio, Evie
to EBIT ratio, and Eb to gross profit. Now
I need to grab the LSC method from up here.
Actually, I just thought a better way to do
this, what we're going to do is we're going
to delete this, we're going to create a empty
pandas list, and we're going to call that
value percentiles. And we want to grab this
same for loop here. So for metric metrics
duckies. And we are going to say value underscore
percentiles, dot append. And then we are going
to grab the value from the corresponding percentile.
Awesome. We want netwrix indexing metric.
Alright, we are going to now just do this
over one iteration of the loop to make sure
it works properly. And before we do that,
we actually have in here to calculate the
mean of this value percentiles. Yes. And inside
the loop, we are going to correct the RV DataFrame.
Awesome. Now, one other thing we can do to
test this actually is printed out value percentiles.
Alright, so to make sure this is working properly,
all we have to do is compare this to this,
you can see the same, we have to compare this
to this, you can see that the same, we have
to compare this to this and you can see that
they're the same. And we have to compare this
to this, and this to this. Awesome, so that
is working properly. And what we can do now
is delete these print statements. Make this
loop iterate over the entire panda's data
frame. And then inside the loop, we can print
the RV underscore data frame. Awesome, you
can see all of our percentile scores were
correctly calculated. And now we can move
on to calculating. Now we can move on to selecting
the 50 best value stocks. Great. So as before,
we can use the panda sword value method to
identify the 50 best stocks in our universe
according to the RV score column. So to do
that, we access our RV data frame, we call
the store values method on it. And then in
here, we have to pass in a few things we have
to pass in the column we want to sell it on.
And then we have to specify the ascending
method. And we want this ascending to be true
because we want the lowest valuation metrics
at the top. And then we have to specify in
place once that's done, we can print our panda's
data frame outside of this or values given
like this to see what modifications have been
made. All right, so now you can see the cheapest
stocks according to a basket of different
valuation metrics. We have Kohl's we have
FTI. I'm not actually sure what company that
is, but we can find it pretty easily FTI stock
and it's technic FMP. It looks like they're
a global oil and gas company. It makes sense
that they're cheap right now because oil prices
are so low Asia HFC is hollyfrontier Corp.
They are also an oil and gas company. And
Al is an airline. They are priced very cheaply
right now because the entire travel industry
has experienced significant headwinds due
to the covid 19 pandemic. And HP I believe
is Hewlett Packard. I note Yeah, Hewlett Packard
enterprises and they make printers and those
sorts of things. They've kind of always traded
a pretty cheap valuation. So that's that.
On the other end of the spectrum, you can
see what stocks are trading at extremely high
valuations. So dx cm, I believe is dex calm.
They make continuous glucose monitoring. Yep,
they make continuous glucose monitoring systems
for diabetes management. Now I'm not sure
what stock that is, but we can find out now.
This is ServiceNow and they're an American
software company. Every software company in
the world is trading at pretty high multiples
right now that we have AMD they make CPUs
and other sorts of computer hardware just
like Nvidia and then pa yc i think is paychecks
which is a it is paychecks they are a payment
processing company. Not pay comm although
they're in the same business. It's an American
online payroll and human resource technology
provider based in Oklahoma City. Okay, so
that's done. What we need to do now is we
need to drop all of the stocks that are after
50th index. So to do that, we will say RV
underscore data frame is equal to RV underscore
data frame at index zero to index 50. And
I actually didn't print that. So what we can
do now our data frame. Great. So this looks
like it's been truncated to only contain the
50 cheapest stocks in our universe to make
sure that there's like 50, what we can say
is we want to calculate the length of the
index of the data frame. And that is 50. Awesome.
The only other thing we need to do is we need
to filter or sorry, not filter, we need to
reset the index of a panda's data frame. And
we saw before that we do reset underscore
index. And then we want to pass drop equals
true into it to avoid duplicating the existing
index of the panda's data frame. And then
we also want to pass in, in places where it's
true. And like all the other instances, including
right here, what this in place equals true
parameter does is it means we're gonna actually
modify the original panda's data frame instead
of just returning a modified version temporarily.
So we already have our data frame and see
what this looks like. Awesome. So now our
index goes from zero, I should finish up 49.
Yep. And these are the 50 cheapest stocks
in our universe. So now that we've selected
the 50 best value stocks, we can move on to
calculating the number of shares to buy. Now,
earlier in this Jupyter Notebook, we defined
a portfolio input function that will allow
us to easily create our portfolio size. So
to do that, we will say portfolio underscore
size, we will run this by itself, and then
we will enter a string object does not call
it a poll. Why is that? That's because we
need to pass in portfolio input in our portfolio
size. All right, now we want to enter the
value of our portfolio. So that's going to
be a million dollars. So one and then six
zeros 123123. Actually, let's spice things
up a bit and do something different. So we'll
do two and a half million to two, five, and
then five zeros. 12345. Awesome. Now let's
print our portfolio, size object or variable
i should say, can make sure that it's stored
correctly. Awesome. Now we need to calculate
our position size. And we've done this twice
now first in our equal weight s&p 500 strategy
and then in our momentum strategy. So you
should be good to do this on your own, I would
encourage you to pause this video and try
to do it by yourself. But if you want to follow
along, you can. So to do this, we will say
position, size is equal to and then the numerator
of this division is going to be the portfolio
size variable that we just created. And the
denominator is going to be the length of our
panda's data frame. So I've mentioned this
in earlier videos, but I prefer to just do
the length of the RVM store data frame index,
and then we can print our position size. Now,
what does this give us an unsupported operand
type for string and integer. That's because
I actually ran into this problem in the momentum
project as well, we need to force this to
be a float. Now what is this giving us $50,000.
And if you think about it, our portfolio is
two and a half million dollars. And there's
505 stocks in our sorry, 50 stocks in our
universe. So if we want to make sure that
this is right, we can just test using the
double equality operator, whether the position
size is equal to two and a half million divided
by 50. And if this returns true, then we know
that the calculation has been done properly.
Awesome. Now, we need to figure out how many
shares of each stock we need to buy to reach
a position size of $50,000 in each stock.
So to do that, just like before, we're going
to create a for loop that loops through every
row of our panda's data frame. So we'll say
for row in our VM, so data frame index, and
make sure that's living properly, we'll just
print them that should go from zero 49. And
it does, which is awesome. And then we will
say RV underscore DataFrame, LLC. And in here,
the first thing that we need to put in is
the row, the second thing we need to put in
is the number of shares the by column. And
to make sure that's working properly, let's
just print it out. The reason I always test
these LLC methods is because sometimes if
you type the column title wrong, it won't
work. And it looks like that's exactly what
happened here. So let's see what happened.
We have number of shares to buy. And to see
what the difference is I'm going to scroll
up to where we originally defined that column
title, and I'm going to paste it beside it.
So that's way up here. And so we have number
of shares to buy number of shares to buy.
They look the same to me. Maybe that's not
actually what the error was. Let's go back
down and actually read the error message that
could help during handling of the above session,
okay, key error Okay, let's print out our
column names to see what's going on. Number
of, Oh, my soul, it is it is just a typo,
I didn't put an S on share. So that's the
problem. And now this prints out all the entries
in our number of shares to buy column. Of
course, that's not what we want, we need to
actually change the value of those cells in
the panda's data frame. So to do that, we'll
use the assignment operator, the equal sign,
and then we need to do a division. So what
goes on the top, it's our position size. And
then in the numerator, we need to figure out
our stock price. So to do that, we will use
another LLC and paste it there, we will replace
the column with price. And that should be
all we need to calculate the number of chairs
we need to buy. So now that that's done, let's
print out our V data frame and run this code.
So great. So we can see here that for calls,
it says by 2000 shares for FDI, it says by
6500 shares. And you'll notice that since
we use the bigger portfolio size, these numbers
are just broadly larger than when we use the
$1 million portfolio size, which makes sense.
You can also quickly sanity check this by
looking at this stock, it has a lower stock
price than this stock. And because of that,
you need to buy many more shares of that stock
to reach the required position size. So everything
looks to be good here. The only other thing
we need to modify is to say math dot floor.
And what this does is it rounds every entry
in that number of shares to by column down
to the nearest integer, for all the reasons
that we described in the first two projects
of this course. So that is done, we can now
move on to formatting our Excel output. Great.
So just like before, the first thing we need
to do is create our writer object. And to
do that, we will say writer is equal to PD
dot Excel writer. And then in here, we have
to pass in a few things. The first thing we
have to pass in is the name of the Excel file
that we want to create, which is value underscore
strategy dot XLS x x x x x s LS. And then
the next thing we need to pass in is the engine,
the engine that we use here, just like before,
is XLS x writer. Now to make sure this is
working properly, you can just do the render
dot save method that we have learned about
earlier. And then if you go into the folder
that we're working in starter files, you should
see the file here, and it should just be empty.
So here it is. And if you click on it, it's
just an empty XML document, which is awesome,
because we haven't done any work on it yet.
So what we need to do now is we can delete
this save method from that code. So now we
need to access our RV data frame. And we use
the to excel method to pass in the name of
to pass in a panda's data frame to the Excel
file that we're working with. Now this takes
three things, you have to say Reiter, and
then you have to say she underscore name is
equal to the value strategy. And then you
have to pass in index equals false. And this
just means that the index here will get passed
into the panda's data frame. So we'll do all
that. That creates our fantasy frame. The
next section is that we need to create the
format's that we'll need for our XLS x file.
And you'll recall from our first project that
we've already have lots of practice with creating
these formats. And since we've already done
this, we're just going to run this code cell
and then continue through this tutorial. So
the next thing we need to do is actually apply
these formats to each of our columns. And
to do that, we're going to start by creating
a dictionary and then we will loop through
that dictionary afterwards. So let's go up
here to where we first created the columns
of our panda's data frame. And from there,
we will paste them in and create a dictionary.
So here's all of our columns, we will scroll
to the bottom to paste those in here, we'll
get the indexing set up properly. And then
we will say column formats equals. And there
is I'm going to add this to its own line,
and then I'm going to put this ticker on a
new line. And then I'm going to get the indenting.
Awesome, that looks a bit better. What we
need to do now is actually format this like
a dictionary. So I'm going to use the multi
cursor functionality of this Jupyter Notebook
to add my cursor to every one of these. And
then I'm going to add some boilerplate each
of these lines. So the first thing we're gonna
do is specify a column. I'm going to put a
on each line and then we'll fix it afterwards.
Then we need to put the semi colon which define
basically is the defining characteristic of
a Python dictionary. And then we're going
to create a Python list and to do that, we're
going to move everything At the end of each
line, there we go, we're back one and then
add the closing list character. The other
thing we're going to do is move back another
one, and add in a comma, and then string underscore
format. Now, this worked well for every every
line except for a few. So it's always good
to go through and just sanity check these,
that one needed a bit of work and this one
here, something wrong with it, that used to
go there, and we can delete that. Okay, I'm
going to just run this code to see if this
is formatted properly. It's not string format
is not defined. Okay, that's because it's
called string template, that is not good.
What I'm going to do is do a Find and Replace.
So I haven't showed you guys this yet. But
it's an interesting feature added up real
quick, if you hit Edit here, and then scroll
down to find replace, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to search for string underscore
format, and replace all of those with string
underscore template. Boom, that fixes that
problem. Now, if I run this code, show code
cell, we should be good to go. And we are
so that is awesome. What I need to do now
is change the column letters for each of these.
So I hope you guys all know your alphabet
will go A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, J, and R.
All right, now we can actually move on to
formatting our our Excel file. So what we'll
do to start is we will say for column in column
underscore format stuff. So what this does
is it loops through all of the column letters
that are keys of this dictionary, and make
sure that's working properly. Let's just print
out all the column letters, it loops from
a through n, and the dictionary goes from
a through n. So that is good. Now what we
need to do is we need to call writer dot sheets.
And then we need to access the sheet that
we named our panda's data frame, and that
is value strategy. So we will copy that, we
will move back down here and we will paste
that in there. And then we would call the
set column method. And you'll recall that
this takes a few different parameters, it
takes the columns and that will look like
that it takes the column width, so we'll use
25 pixels. And then it takes the format that
will look something like this string underscore
template. Now, I'm going to run this loop.
And you'll notice that the statement that
is being run with each loop doesn't actually
change with response to the loop so that this
is just going to make sure that this is working
properly for column A. And then once that's
done, we can go into about changing the values
for each iteration of the loop. I'm also going
to call the writer dot save method to save
it. And we can now look in our working directory
to see if this has formatted column A successfully
and it has, so we can now move on to interpolate
values into this. So here we want to use column.
And we need to change this to an F strings
that actually interpolate properly, we need
to use column there. And then here, we need
to access the second item of this list. So
to do that, we will say I can't quite scroll
this up enough to get it away from my webcam
there. That should be okay. So here we want
to say column underscore formats at column.
So this gives us the list and then we want
the second item of that list. So we'll try
that and now we'll see what our data frame
looks like. Actually, to do that, we need
to go back up here and run all this awesome,
grow working directory, open this up. And
they've all been formatted with the string
format. So that is good. What we need to do
now is we need to go up here and actually
change the format that's being applied to
each one. So we have string template, dollar
template, integer template, flow template
and percent template. And this float template
here actually did wrong this should be 0.0.
We're on that. And then we'll go through here
and change its format according to what should
be dollar this should be an integer. This
should be a float. P percentile should be
a percent. price to book ratio should be a
float. price to book ratio percentile should
be a percent, price to sales ratio should
be a float. So sales ratio percentile should
be a percent indash should be a float. Even
a percentile should be a percent. You need
to gt should be a float. Maybe a GP percentile
should be a percent and robust value score
should also be a percentage because it is
an average of all the different percentiles
in our panda's data frame. So we'll run all
this again and see what this looks like. Awesome.
So we have ticker, which is a string price,
which is $1 number of shares to buy, which
is an integer price to earnings ratio, which
is a float p percentile. Everything looks
to be good here. Great. So the only other
thing that needs change about this is that
we need to format our columns. And we also
need to change our percentiles, because just
like in the momentum project, they are two
orders of magnitude bigger than what they
should be. So we'll fix the percentile score
calculations first, that's pretty easy, all
I need to do is scroll up to here, find the
loop where we calculated our percentile scores
calculated by percentiles. So if we divide
this by 100, and that should fix the problem.
So we can do this, run a bunch of code cells,
do a two and a half million dollar portfolio
again, and then we're back down to the format
error. So I'm actually gonna go through all
of this and save it again, just to make sure
that that was done properly. If we open this
up, and we go here, we can now see that the
percentiles all range from zero to 100, as
desired. Awesome. The next thing we need to
do is actually format our column headers.
So to do that, we will say, writer dot sheets,
and then passing values strategy, select these
sheets that we want to format, and then we
call the right method. Now, you'll recall
that the right method takes a few different
things and takes the cell we want to write.
So this will be for each row, or sorry, for
each column, it will be the the first cell
of that column, so we'll say, column, and
then one. So that's the first cell of that
column. The second thing we need is the actual
value that we want to write into that cell.
So that will be the first entry of each of
these lists just like before, so we paste
that in and use index zero. And then the last
thing that it takes is the format that you
want to apply to that cell so that just like
the set column method that we use here is
going to be the second entry of that list.
So we will pass it index one. Alright, so
that should be all the formatting. What I'm
going to do next is just move this writer
dot save down to here, I'm going to delete
all of these empty cells. And then I'm going
to scroll back up to where we created our
Excel file. I'm going to run all the code,
and you should be good to go. So this started
here, so I'm going to click that and then
do Shift Enter until I reached the end of
the Jupyter Notebook. And here's our final
spreadsheet. So as you can see, all the formats
have been applied successfully. And you have
now created a quantitative value investing
strategy that identifies the 50 cheapest stocks
in the s&p 500 using a basket of different
valuation metrics. And that concludes our
third project. So kudos to you for making
it all the way through this algorithmic trading
and Python course.